see if we can get in a checkmate but try
to just right now just try to take out
all your pieces
so try to bring your your bishop because
he's been neglected
okay that's a that's a good pawn move um
let's say
i'm going to make room to take out my
light squared bishop
oh yeah queen okay
um that do you see what peace
is hanging with that plant bush
um this um this the bishop is
this is my bishop's attacking rook right
yeah yeah yeah okay
let's say i don't see it okay
so maybe i'll show him oh i'll show him
one
checkmate well i don't even know i don't
know if it's worth it to show him queen
okay so was this a good oh i'm in check
never mind oh oh this is
yeah yeah so i did that yeah good
fantastic so i can't take your night
cause i'm in check good good
hopefully you'll have enough pieces um
so because i don't think we have enough
time to go over the basic checkmates
but if he knows captures and attacks and
just takes all of austin's pieces
or like tickle his pieces and promote a
pawn to a queen
that'd be okay so let's see how he beats
me here
even though your night was hanging your
night was a free piece
so okay first you have okay
good i'm good you're bringing all your
pieces to my king
let's say this is a free piece
um what piece of yours is under attack
um the h2
um true okay anything else and
i suppose the knight next to the king
how many times am i attacking the night
uh twice and how many times are you
defending it
um none i'm not sure
you're defending it with one piece which
i was a good move it was your last move
oh okay
well what piece is defending your knight
is it the
um i'm not totally sure is it it's the
bishop
so the bishop on g5 because it moves on
that diagonal
so let's say i take it oh it's your turn
actually it's your move
um the bishop so the knight is in one
square diagonally away right
um so okay but i don't want to spend too
much time defending
um so let's just try to set up a
checkmate here
try good okay so this is the trade i was
trying to tell you so here
you lost a piece um right because
i was attacking it twice and you were
defending it once right
um good okay oh thank you leslie for the
raid
okay try to prepare the checkmate by
bringing in more pawns or your other
rook
let's try to do we're going to try to do
a ladder checkmate yeah
which you probably have no idea what
that means but i'll explain it good
um okay or try to promote that's a
better plan actually
okay so how could you promote here
i can promote here um no no no but you
want
a plan to promote so try to get your
pawn all the way to the end of the board
oh okay which was good you defended okay
you defended a past
pawn with your rook um that that is not
the past pawn
oh but when you played rookie one you're
supporting a very strong pawn plane
where you can just push him all the way
to the end
okay the problem with that one is i'm
gonna be able to capture it
so not that pawn what about a different
pawn that has no
pawns um nearby it in the front
this one yes that's one okay so let's
say i don't do anything about it
even though actually am i attacking
anything with that knight move
um yeah you're attacking
c4 and also one more piece
but with not with my knight um
i guess h2 still yes
and when i moved my knight i opened up
one of my pieces
oh yeah yeah yeah good okay so now you
just have to play fast and i'm gonna
explain to you two tournament things and
we're just gonna throw you to throw you
in and
you're going to beat up boston it's
going to go great it's going to go
awesome so
first save your rook and then let's push
that past pawn get a queen and just
checkmate me
okay don't take that that was not the
okay do you know why that was a bad
square
yeah because you can just take it i
thought i was just going to get the
queen
okay good but okay if you know that they
can take it against austin don't play it
yes right yeah i really don't think
austin's gonna go for scholars but i'll
show him it
real quick okay let's go for it
okay um so the best move in that
position would have been just pushing
your pawn and you gave me a free rook
because that rook was not defended but
i'm not gonna take it
let's see can you play that rook in a
square that is defended
well now okay that rook was hanging but
it's okay just promote your queen
promote the queen um as in keep pushing
your pawn
okay okay so here what am i forced to do
what piece do i have to move
you have to move the king because we're
in
check good okay
oh oof if you promote now what could i
do
you could take it good so can you try to
defend that square
you have to bring in one more piece i'll
give you a hit it's your other rook
bring your rook to defend the e8 square
defend e8 how do i what is that what do
i do
um so you have to put the rank on the
same line as that pawn because
so if you push e8 my rook will take but
then what piece can you take back with
this um close
the problem there is that that's a free
piece right right
um let's say okay
okay say i play here so the best square
oh i can't show you
arrows would have been on e6
so let's try it again do you see the e6
square
yes okay so try to get your rook to e6
okay you want to bring the other rook
but you know what let's just say
wait how how would i do that in one turn
though oh no you'd have to you'd have to
take two turns
but uh okay it's okay all right i made a
losing move
let's see if you can beat me
um try to attack my king
he's vulnerable on the of the back rank
nothing is defending him
good okay and now if you make the best
move
it'll be good it'll be game over
okay good so that was checkmate because
i'm under attack and can't run anywhere
yeah
right okay i'm gonna show you scholars
make really quick and then you can play
um one thing armageddon so if you win
[Music]
one
so
[Music]
welcome everybody to the pogchamps day
three
coverage with uh boys levy rosman
kikaru in his seat and ludwig welcome
back to the show
glad to be back glad to be joined by you
levy a true
master of not only commentary but chess
itself
uh you've coached a couple people here
do you wanna let's just say who you
coached first
and then when we see how well they do we
can all commend you
okay that sounds good yes we can just do
roulette uh
first we're gonna pull up the standings
we're not even gonna show how intensely
i was staring at the camera there ready
for criticism
uh we've got all of group c taking on
each other today uh cutie cinderella
going up against tf blade
tsm xexra will be taking on dog dog
uh but first guys but first
we have austin show and connor eats
pants
that's not on the screen but um what are
your thoughts
maybe hicaro get us going yeah so um
i think certainly with group group c
where we're much more familiar with the
players we had a last-minute replacement
miss kiff dropping out um and conor eats
chance replacing him um i i'm sure
there's some joke behind that
behind that twitch name um but anyway
yeah mischief last-minute dropout so we
have this match between austin and
connery's pants i think it's gonna be
very close i was watching connor eats
pants a little bit earlier
and um it looked like he has some good
understanding of the basics at least so
it could be an uphill battle for austin
but i think it's gonna be a fun match
nonetheless
i think this will be the world's worst
chess game
ever it's just gonna be the worst chess
game that you've ever seen hikaru
there will be so many blunders i think
it'll be the most fun game of the entire
tournament to watch though
i just grimaced a little bit uh not
because ludwig was talking but because i
went to type forward slash follow conor
eats pants and i don't know what he's
drilling right now
but uh is this is this
already is this game over is this his
position
uh no no he's been doing well he's been
doing lessons with andre i think she's
trying to teach him a thing
so this is his position no um
yeah i think no it's actually credit to
andrea because she had to catch connor
up to speed
um what a weird dynamic there by the way
isn't alexandra coaching austin
isn't that oh yeah yeah they've
definitely done coaching before yeah so
we're gonna get to see which sister is
the better coach i mean plain and simple
that's the reality of the situation
minds of the sister and then these
players are they're puppets
i'm excited for this match look i think
the worse they are the more fun a chess
game is
because it becomes less about you know
great positioning and all that and then
it becomes you know very swingy
that it doesn't matter how deep into the
game you are if there's maintenance ii
you can still choke at any moment so i
think it'll be hype i also think conor's
probably as good as miz was uh because
miz
you know he was great in his own right
he's done a lot for the game of chess
i just think you know conor's probably
at miz's level
uh you and me are gonna balance did a
lesson with the gentleman
directly below you ever played chess
before in the middle uh all the time
me neither he gets what i would say is
uh yeah wait wait wait am i on the right
side i don't know even
i don't know if it's against the rules
i'm down the top during the game but it
might be against the rules
and we're going to see some some weird
uh some weird chess
i am pretty sure uh that i am following
both of the players uh we were waiting
for austin
to boot up it seems to be a recurring
theme sometimes they do scare us
as if like they're going to play their
games but not necessarily stream them
did forsen stream his games or was he
more focused this time around
two days ago hikara you were on that
show right um yeah forza was on the zoom
call he was on the zoom call okay so
um i think that's that's the reason is
uh is as forsen
he i think he did this in pog champs one
where there was one or two matches as
well where he was on zoom and he did not
stream it i think for
two people in particular um mr xqc
and mr forsen they both um they both
have such a big audience and i think in
some ways they get really distracted
when they
when they're streaming the games as well
so uh they're the two guys that it makes
the most sense for in terms of um in
terms of not not streaming while they're
playing but yeah i think it's it's going
to be fun to see what happens um
in in in these games today and uh what
i'm just really looking forward to so we
have some great chess the first two days
and um and i'm expecting more great
shots today on the third day
you're expecting great chess today
that's uh
great job all right so if that's what
you're expecting great chess it is
i might be expecting it but i feel like
if i could actually predict the future
then i would be doing something more
important than watching streaming
commentary right now i
i think i think we have a game i think
the game is live
connery spans with the white pieces what
did andrea show him for her first move
all right so the mind of andrea with
conor the mind of alexandra with austin
uh and both these new chess players will
show off their skills
i don't even think that conor knows that
it's a game by the way not to cut you
off but i don't think he knows it's this
move
yeah i don't know if he knows that white
goes first that's not for sure
but that's fine because it's game sense
you guys don't understand is raw
fundamental game sense okay doesn't
matter you don't even know these
first horse nitty-gritties in an l these
are details game sense kicks in
when he goes for the kill to check mate
so look he's he's running down the clock
right now to make austin a little bit
nervous i can tell
uh so there's no restarts right
um so someone's not someone conor has to
make him and he's done it he's moved his
knight out
okay good start good start um
well jessica yeah i've just opened up
the audio channel on the
uh on conor's twitch and and they're
talking to each other
which i think i think might be a pog
chance first
seriously yeah the opponents are
communicating with each other
well let's listen in they are they are
they are yeah let's just listen in real
quick to conor's channel and see uh
what they're saying to each other
let's see here say
interesting strategy there connor with
your pony
yeah you scared a little bit a little
bit afraid i don't know if you know what
you're doing
called it a pony um with that movie i'm
totally in your head right now oh my god
see this is this is 800 elo things you
wouldn't get it
i can't believe honestly that you have
that high you wouldn't understand what
it's like to have 800 elo
i think you bothered your account i
would never buy anything
the only thing i bought is my lowest it
could be with a new account
on you in the beginning and then i'm
going to come in and you know honestly
frankly just kick your ass
that was a really interesting move here
you made it very simple for me
um i don't think that's true we'll trade
oh no
uh you might not even see actually
that's not a trick i don't know why you
made that move connor
because uh yeah that was a that was bold
i'm simply in your head
yeah that was bold i don't know why you
did that
well we can maybe bring it back to the
analysis board
but yeah um we should probably
demonstrate why
oh no oh guys how long was the lesson
between andrea
and uh conor well you know it wasn't the
longest lesson but i want to go back to
the
game sense levy here because if conor
has his queen
all right king of all sims he will make
the thing
happen he will get the job done so sure
maybe he blundered here
you know a couple okay maybe the board
says he's supposed
to be down seven pawns but i think end
of the game
that's when austin will be nervous
right right right and is that going to
be this played a terrible move too
um yeah just oh
that that's yeah you can just open up
his king right
what was the better move instead of
pushing the pawn uh-huh
uh literally moving up the other pawn
well you could do that but also what i
was going to say as well as um you could
also just move the knight out
instead of the pawn like put the knight
on f6 for example as well
but yeah anything anything but f6
anything but f6
yeah literally any other move was good
basically and so now
now we'll see yeah i mean when in doubt
you know you should try to
develop your pieces i like and i like
how conor's getting all his pieces out
uh but it would have been better instead
of bishop h3 to obviously move the
bishop to g2
on a serious note as serious as i can
put this
uh sometimes beginners they move a
bishop like this and they think i'm
attacking their bishop with my bishop
but the bishop can just take them well i
mean i mean to be fair love he's he
there's a good chance that connor maybe
is so new to the game that he's
confusing chess with shot raunch which
was the old chess about 2 000 years ago
of course in old chats you can only move
the bishop to squares so
i can understand he might have had a
different thought in mind yeah
actually so true because he was he just
kept bringing up shot roger we were
playing fall guys
so that's probably a ziti car good call
there
i will say in the coaching lesson andrea
said i have one goal for you this game
it wasn't win all right it wasn't check
it was castle so he's kind of close
no he's not i'm not gonna get it right
side because i don't know if he knows
about castling through check and how
you're not able to do that
but eventually it will come
well um yeah maybe um left side
yeah but what you know what i would say
is it's actually the problem for uh for
austin here is he has to find that pawn
move that ludwig mentioned where he
moves upon in front of his king so
otherwise he's gonna have trouble
getting the pieces into the game on the
right side his bishop knight and rook
okay they're both pushing f pawns
they've met in the middle uh now neither
one of them can
okay does austin know bishops go
backwards
austin is not looking very happy so i'm
not sure
i don't think so look i i don't even all
the time know that they go backwards
it's just not something you look at i
think in your mind you categorize
pieces as certain things all right this
is my attacking piece it's always
looking down at the king
and then you just forget about it you've
just locked it in your mind as that
and i think a good thing to do for
beginners is to re-look at the board
and then for you know forget what you've
written down as truth
and try to try to recognize hey maybe i
missed something
right i will no if you give himself the
opportunity here maybe you can pull it
off
i i'm i'm trying to put a a stamp of
logic on the move rook c7 can one of you
please help me out i i really
is he defending his king pawn i
think i remember playing chess when i
was really young against my uncle
and thinking that man this rook is a
piece of [__]
this guy does not want to ever be in a
helpful position
i have to like move them up move them
right and move them up
and i think that might be where austin's
head's at it's going for like the
four-move rook setup just so he's
somewhat useful uh because maybe he sees
the
knight and doesn't see a way to
immediately attack it and recognizes
that yeah i could bring my rook down
many ways maybe he pushes his pawn up
here that'd be great push his pawn up
then brings the rook over
mm-hmm maybe that's what's going on it's
not a bad move at all
uh well if the bishop
never comes back to take the knight at
night's gonna be a little bit annoying
so if austin finds a way to kick it out
he does have both pawn moves
he can attack with the queen which would
be interesting because the bishop and
the queen are equidistant at that moment
let's play a little game how many turns
do you think the bishop will be able to
take the night before
it's either noticed or no longer an
option
i'm gonna say five moves five moves okay
levy you're going higher or lower over
under five
five points i i go
i go three i'm going lower i'm going i'm
going over
i'm thinking of solid we're doing moves
is not both right
i believe that's that's something yeah
we'll just do like one move for white
yeah like one two three four just
straight forward yeah in show wait and
chess
actual terminology is a move both
players yeah it's technically
and then the individual move is called
something else right what is that
there's a known word for it like if just
one person does something
like half a move uh
you guys don't know this this is why we
have ludwig on the show
oh i'm sorry hey guys it's called apply
okay but yeah fly actually is computer
terminology but still
yeah yeah that's technically probably
what you call it like yeah
gm's are handed out to anyone these days
i guess
okay so we saw one move though right
there was one how many turns has he
missed tonight
he's had at least two or three already
to capture oh right yeah for sure
okay well i think the knight he's moved
it i win
oh wow good call okay
but at the same time he went to the one
square
that black is protecting more than any
other square on the board
yeah he had um
i mean he hadn't really nowhere to go
right i i don't think
he could have gone back to one square on
the edge of the board but that was it
and that was not a normal
in order to go forward which i think is
is how their minds are working right now
is forward only
correct right have they moved backwards
once every move has been forward
that is actually that's true yeah no not
yet i think
they won't move backwards until they're
forced to move backwards
all right bishop takes yeah nice
so so far this game's kind of shaping
into what i'd hoped it'd be
wanna want to listen in listen to some
awesome banter let's
let's get in on some banter completely
completely honestly
it did not make sense at all no
truly but uh it was bold i appreciate
that
yeah i was trying to be bold um just
kind of threw that out there but
it was not the play it was not okay it
really really
wasn't an incredibly bold thought
turns out you don't you're in my head
now i am i'm in your head
the clock's ticking mostly sound like a
baseball broadcaster oh god
i had it i'm gonna be honest with you i
had a game plan maybe
and then currently i have lost that game
plan
yeah you you're lost i'm very lost
you're getting outplayed by someone with
400 elo how does that feel what the hell
was that
i moved the pawn i i know but why wh
what was the strategy behind that i'm
leaving it out okay
all right well all right
don't really know what maybe maybe we
bring it back to deep dive into the move
on to a5 oh pawns a6 austin stubbornly
declining
his opponent the opportunity to go any
further now let's talk about this a5
movie
let's talk about it obviously there's a
game plan in mind walk us through the
line after a5
right so hikaru uh you wanna yeah i
think the thing is
what ludwig said you hit the nail you
hit the with you hit the nail on the
head basically which is that um
he's just trying to go forward every
move is forward so
like i think if we believe in that logic
he just played g4
so he's trying to just go forward with
every piece so he's going to move like
i'm going to predict he plays either
pawn one of the two pawns up or he's
going to move the rook to a4 i think
if he plays if he plays rook a4 right
now i will gift your channel 20 subs if
he sees rook a4
okay okay i i would be mind blown
really if he's using yeah i don't think
is it that excellent of a move
no no no i just i just i mean well i
think the thing that i that levy's
saying is that it's not a natural move
like he thinks it's
so unnatural but lovey why do you think
it's so unnatural when he's trying to go
forward i'm kind of curious i'm trying
to get
into the mind of a player who was trying
to fill
the shoes of somebody like mischief just
having this and he's played
the first backwards move of the game
bishop g1
connor an innovator of the game of chess
i think he went back a little too far
though
ludwig do you see the trap do you see
the way to win here when there's a
tactical trap now since he went back too
far
uh yeah i mean the bishop right you can
just you can just move the bishop to
g2 and then yeah very good useless
very nice this should be yeah let's be
clear here
look okay miss gift dropped out all
right chess.com reaches out they say
ludwig look
we need you and i and i and i said to
the guys that says the guys
i could at any moment
walk all over these players
earn all the money at the top of
winner's bracket this time
but i'm retired okay sometimes sometimes
you feel like you've done all you can
for the game
the beautiful game and you just got to
walk away
i don't know if you ever felt like that
yet or do you feel like you have more to
do
i don't know if you've felt this yet no
i have not felt this knot at all really
really i've talked to magnus about it a
bit so right
right your fellow scandinavian yeah we
are both the same me
magnus and uh hop thor all scandinavian
some of us just got gifted different
things
very true very true i would like to
wager both oh okay um
that move is actually potentially
brilliant because
conor is attacking the bishop and he and
he got it
oh my god
now and look at austin recoil
yeah his face is so let's listen in oh
my god
that was that was really awesome
thanks i didn't expect that out of you
i did not expect that out of you i went
and i got the guy
that was a brilliant move he got the gun
taking advantage of your
can anyone who is
you're under the influence no austin
it's 4 p.m
um connor it's not it's 1 p.m
i'm on the west coast oh my goodness
wait i thought you were i can't
interrupt this banter
wait what oh i don't know why i thought
that no no no
no okay you think austin lived in austin
how about you live on the west coast
let's talk about that what are you doing
where do you live atlanta why would you
live in atlanta
because it's not the west coast ugh
you don't even know what time zone
you're in you're like on the edge i'm on
the cannon times i don't even know what
time zone i'm in
god atlanta
he not where'd you austin stop
texas in the middle of the country who
was he trying to insult
the falcons ugh don't bring the falcons
into this too far
ah the falcons don't bring the falcons
into this austin come on
unnecessary doing that well hey how was
that
how was that super bowl unless that's
unnecessary do you realize how much that
hurt me
no i yeah that was a tough day
yeah oh don't do this oh i don't like
this
big mistake i don't like this austin i
know
i don't like my situation right now i
know you're in a bad spot i will say
really connor's they really are knight
to d5
it's all right in a bad spot you're in a
really bad attack
i don't know if i don't know if austin
will see nope
yep nope
maybe you'll see the queen threat and
then think to defend the queen you suck
oh my god he's going for it what
yeah yeah you heard me austin
yeah that's right connor i'm getting
inside your head you're going awesome
no need
that's right conor you heard me
oh that's an interesting move that you
just did there you scared
nope i'm scared i'm not even playing i'm
terrified
oh my goodness i am terrified well he
tried to castle one way oh
austin's scared
okay oh f5 so
the reason why all of this is completely
falling off a cliff
every single time guys is because of
knight takes c2
that's it because and rookie
oh my god it's check though it's check
now
after queen takes work you can't take
the pawn because the black king is in
shock
yeah i also think that if conor
finds still knight to d5 the knight will
never move back austin's knight will
never move
back i believe that to be truth i think
you can
cheese that if you know that information
and then use that as a pseudo tactic
right a pseudo tactic
at this rate i would i would be very
worried if i was austin because
i'm not sure the players are familiar
exactly with the time format it's ten
minute five second bonus
uh and i think yeah
i think austin's recognized this he's
moved faster and i think he's
actually trying to make connor move
slower okay by
talking to him what oh come on
that was insane oh
[Applause]
are you kidding me i thought i was gonna
get you on the next
[Music]
oh my gosh let's see
that was just did you just move no
okay now
hard to lie about this is dangerous very
dangerous
he hasn't immediately recognized that it
was a blunder
i think he's looking at the queen
[Music]
and
this could be huge here if conor
recognizes what he has right
[Music]
did you play that chess play test things
oh
[Music]
so now he's in check austin's only
thoughts will be how do i move this king
out of check
like hikaru said even though this is a
clear take
from the bishop it shouldn't happen you
could go two
and then down one oh my gosh we gotta go
two and down one we gotta we gotta
get on the board here i have to say
see the thing is austin's got 90 seconds
to get out of check
yeah and if you go you gone i was just
going to say on chess.com when you try
to make your legal moves your king
flashes
if that setting is not on there is a
legitimate chance that he doesn't find
an escape
well i it should i feel like at the end
of the day if he's really nervous he'll
just move the king
right because he can move the king in a
lot of legal spaces here
which is what he ends up doing uh and
now this is what i was saying about this
game this is why i was excited about
this game peop
like maybe they're bad right maybe
they're terrible
they're not the fact of the matter is
how many games can you watch
where you blunder your queen by moving
it right next to a king with absolutely
no defense
and still be in it you don't see this at
the world series
yes correct that event doesn't even
exist but it should
it that's a g hey karu that one's on the
house
right yes world series of chess all the
different events yeah i like it
you're full of good ideas
i think he needs to lay down the
pressure
i don't hate that because i don't no
this is bad actually has austin shown a
backward move yet though because again
now
he's going to lose the bishop if he
doesn't see that he can move it
backwards so this is the situation where
the backward move is forced
because he's threatened the bishop
austin's eyes will be trained on the
bishop
no he looks for another good move
that move was winning a lot of times at
this point it's still very good it's a
fork the knight jumps in hits the king
king's now gonna move
somewhere uh and
yeah i think as long as he moves his
king up diagonally it'll be great
because if he moves it sideways he can't
capture the knight
it's still not that big of a deal he can
still take the bishop
austin's got a minute yeah that's true
time does play a factor and i think
communicating with each other is
actually in conor's favor because it's
harder to not only focus on the game but
talk to your opponent
wow wow i did not expect that i thought
he would take the rook for sure
and he's popping off on him
very out of my house
don't think it's time to pop off i got
time i i i can't run out of time here
great good fine from connor oh awesome
i got to keep moving here because if i
don't you do you really celebrate
really don't take okay
why am i oh i'm in a bad spot
no this is bad for you he's very close
to checkmate here
uh i don't know the exact line i would
go h7 with the right rook and then you
just go
c8 with the left rook and then you get
checkmate i don't actually there there's
an easer
oh he just walks into oh yeah
take the knight game he takes the knight
it's gg's if
if he takes the knight oh we have
witnessed the ascension of a title
player wait and he's done it that was
really silly
wow what was his what was his writing
halfway through that game well how it
was like
yes yeah but i would get you the next
turn no matter what you do
how far down he was and the comeback
that he made probably the biggest
comeback in all pogchamps
that might be the biggest comeback in
the history of the chess game
like that it was
it was at its worst when he played the
move queen e3
wow yeah i don't even know wow
he's minus 19 there yeah
because of knight takes c2 and then you
just simply pick up the queen
the family fork but i called that move
genius guys and i i stand by what i said
yeah and this just goes to show that
pseudo tactics
are actually viable at low level play
and by pseudo-tactics i mean doing
something
and praying to god your opponent doesn't
notice all right
putting your place or your piece in a in
a blundered position
but that can only be captured when the
piece moves backwards the opponent's
piece
maybe they don't see that maybe they
don't know about backwards moves that's
not
three head that's five head
wow this game by the way uh is the
perfect example
on a serious note why tactics are so
useful because there's just these
one move you know spots in every game
you just go oh i've seen this a hundred
times before i play knight takes pawn
easy and i and i win the queen and conor
i guess has a good spot for
like this whole idea that he did guys
queen d two queen e3 queen takes bishop
that was clever i mean the guy learned
chess an hour ago
right not bad at all i think that's
intuitive
that you forget when you learn chess and
then you re-remember when you get good
at chess
is like moving your piece into positions
where they're more useful
like what i was talking about with the
rook were you like moving forward and
left maybe it isn't the best
uh there's better ways to do it but the
idea of moving your piece into a
valuable position
uh i think is is like it's like a pretty
common thing to do at low level
i think they are just about on the verge
of playing another game now austin will
have the white pieces
tutelage under alexander botez
very scared what his opening is gonna be
but i think we're gonna listen into
their opening moves their game is not
live yet
any predictions
i think on it austin takes this one
you think we're getting i i think austin
will take it as well i think austin
crumbled a bit there at the end for sure
he made some great moves i think
he sees blunders quicker than conor
which is going to be key here to win
if he figures out the legendary move
backward tactic
game over i also just want to point out
live action learning so move 23 the guy
goes queen eight
and what he probably learned and
retained
from the lesson that he did with andrea
was that if you check the king and it
looks like this it's kind of cramped it
can't move anywhere
it's mate and he was right except for
the fact that
it can take and so a lot of moves later
instead of playing the move rook takes
g8 right around here once
he actually successfully broke through
he hovered over this move and then went
uh oh
wait it's the same thing the king moves
over and takes me and he didn't play it
and he won the game in just a few
moves like literally right afterwards so
analyze adapt ascertain
yes conceive believe achieve luke
rockhold
now hikar i have a quick question does
this inspire you to play more chess
or do we lose your car i
your question might have his camera
froze
yeah he's he's put on the [__]
sunglasses he's taking a nap on this one
he might quit the good game if he
watches another
uh but we are into it are we listening
that's your first move
yes we are why i just don't
i don't like it why are you so afraid
when i when i first learned how to play
i didn't learn that way i didn't either
that's just something i came up with
this is against this is you know a
little off-putting
that's the connor gambit i know you need
it you need to play like they taught me
in the round like i'm only know how to
react to certain moves this is actually
very good
that's not very good oh
geez he just snapped it yeah immediately
i want it all day long i want it
i just i wanted to
thank you i wanted to give it to you
austin i really appreciate that i think
just a little handicap you know what i
mean right oh handicap
get in my head early on yeah all right
is he gonna snap the knight too
i got options here austin i'll be real
yeah i know
i got options you're going to take
something else and i just made a
terrible move
am i though yes oh no don't move the
knight again am i really going to
i don't know if i am you're gonna take
something else it's
coming
you know what connor what oh he really i
really like you
i like you too austin really nice guy
thank you now that's doubly bad
god i'm still in your head right now
let's take bishop i know
then he's also threatening taking the
knight which is also not defended
oh thank you jesus oh no jesus
i think he's gonna go for a very ballsy
play here
he's gonna stop diving his horse into
the opponent's territory uh oh
yeah he's hovering i can't believe he
got away with that either
that was really yeah this is a ballsy
play he's thinking about doing
oh i'm thinking about it austin i know
your time's ticking
i'm thinking about it okay i like that
you're thinking about it okay
that did nothing all right nothing at
all well
um the only thing that did
that was make a pawn hang see where's
the danger
yeah that was a that was a sub-optimal
move oh
but he baited him he baited him wow
oh my five ngm pseudotactic
wizard that's exactly what i wanted you
to do okay oh my god
that is exactly what i wanted you to do
right it was sort of like walked into
connor
just like perfectly encapsulated exactly
what i wanted to do
okay is that are you really thinking
this far ahead yes
i'm thinking three turns down the road i
actually think connor's a better player
um yeah give this man the principles and
i and i think we're going to get a
potential
you're so scared yeah well i knew you
were going to take you're so
scared austin you're learning chess they
say hey you got to learn the principles
and then after you learn them that's
when you get to forget them
uh yeah i i yeah i say that yeah um but
but
skipped the first step he never learned
him
already forgot them and i think he
skipped playing
at an intermediate level to already
playing at an advanced level
right um
[Music]
well uh i don't know
uh if i agree fully i don't like the
he just he doesn't like bishops very
much faded him
that was insane he moved upon ford made
it so
appetizing for the rook and then
literally
did a what four point versus five point
trade right
night night pawn versus an entire rook
yeah he what he the reason he played b5
actually his logic was that
oh i see that if he takes me with the
rook i take with the knight
now there's a lot of reasons why the
move b5 is not a good move because you
can play
you know you can play a move like c5
earlier which would have attacked the
rook and defended the knight for example
uh but yeah thinking about
pseudo tactics exactly thinking that
your opponent will do the right thing
and that's not the the truth they're
operating in
if you assume your opponent does the
right thing you play good moves
if you assume or but if their opponent
actually does bad things then they might
end up being wrong moves
but if you assume they do bad things and
then you do bad things
then those are the right things are you
following here are you following me levy
i am following and no hikaru didn't
uh tilt out of uh watching the game uh
he had a i think his computer died so
we're about to read them let let's
listen in to conor again and we'll get
hikaru back on
the
man time is ticking yeah i had an idea
for a move and then i lost it so now i'm
kind of like reconsidering
i'm gonna do that so why don't you like
[__]
like what's well i mean i do it's just
you know well i know i i know i get it
but like
is there just like a particular reason i
just
it's just not my kind of song okay
that's fair i can respect that the car
is bad now this is uh
i just think it sends a powerful message
you know like i think that's no i agree
i think that's awesome
uh you know and that that that aspect of
the song i think is awesome
true true no complaints there oh
absolutely not
it's not really my thing to full
transparency no i know i know
i do appreciate it
wow you know i just
i don't know why i let that happen i
would i don't know why
connor went to be eight with this i
think that's a great move
what did you take i forgot what you took
i was aggressive in ballsy
uh your mom's covering it are
[Laughter]
yes you confused me because you said b8
and i was going to say it's already on
that square but you meant just
what you traverse the board terrible
now you're fine
see what happens when you go to see see
what happens when you go to see
respect i'm thinking about it and i
don't like the i don't like
okay what this does is it stresses out
austin i think austin might make an
ill-advised
move by moving his bishop at some point
as long as
conor doesn't move the rook right
doesn't take with that rook leaves it
there at some point
austin will feel the need to do some
basic stuff he'll be like okay
what's going on what's going on okay i
need to activate my pieces moves it
and then we'll threaten i think maybe
his queen
i think there's an opportunity for that
to happen i think there's a there's a
future botez gambit
that might come from that rook move
wow wow wow wow okay i mean we
let's let's let's let's check in on this
i love to listen to their banter i mean
let's run it let's run we might as well
take take take this game off
there too i am
um
awesome i'm protected everywhere
not true just don't know what i'm doing
that's fine
they respect that i respect that you
understand that you know
ikaru your car is back did you just take
something
maybe did i i don't know look at the
board
now i'm in trouble but you're in trouble
too see we're all in trouble
part of what happened it is oh i didn't
actually want to do that i actually can
i take that back
you mean you could like highlighting i
mean to do that highlight it and then
doesn't it also tell you the log of
moves on the right
yes yeah the notation yes of course yeah
oh oh no that was that's a
oh no yeah this is an intense game i
mean austin
has to win this thing as i know what you
can do if i did
that which is what makes the game
interesting right
like that that's what makes the game
cool
come on take my pony i don't even want
the pony
come on i really i really have no
interest i have no interest in the pony
austin
you hear it you hear it austin i have
zero interest in the pony
i don't want the pony i think it's the
only reason he didn't take it is because
austin said take it
and the calm is coming into play here
don't make the pony noises again please
by the way i made me a little bit
uncomfortable
uh i just got to get better at this game
i just really do i've never even seen
chess before today
i me neither really truly i i
what are you scared of here what do you
think might happen are you just you're
at a loss
i'm just i feel as though i'm in in a
never
ending line for a roller coaster like
every time it it i go through the ride
i'm just back in the you know
first seat and i'm ready to go again i'm
worried that he will
check the or not check but threaten the
queen here yeah okay that's what i was
worried
about and it did happen oh that was bad
which was yeah which was bad of him that
one's on me
connor that was connor that one respects
his knights and bishops
i didn't think fully i thought i was
thinking too fast
brilliant you really the pawn on this oh
i didn't mean to do that but all right
that was yeah i don't know why you did
that either that was just really
questionable yeah no i've made some
questionable mistakes now i wasn't
really paying full attention
you really had it in the bag and then i
don't know what you you've done
i kind of tossed it it's okay i still i
still believe
yeah i'm back from bigger i think this
game is just going to be who can just
accidentally win no uh do you mean
you deficit or were you going for
another word i'm not i'm not a word
what it's not come on we're better than
that
i feel like a golf commentator right now
you sure i mean i don't know
maybe conor recognizes he can't move the
agency all right
i tell you what i can't really take you
down the flight simulator though i'm
sure you would
i can land the hell out of a plane
okay i'm playing a risky play here
i'm thinking a couple turns ahead but i
am making a risky play
i think he's really hoping that oh you
have no idea what i'm doing do you
oh i know what you're doing then he will
i'm gonna foil it right now oh you have
no idea what i'm doing i'm gonna see he
he's doing this
he actually doesn't know like i do i do
he's baiting yeah oh god it's risky yeah
it's exactly what he's doing
i think that's caught me i could do
something i could do something here
but it's just oh
you fell right from my classic blunder
yep no
insane you fell right for my classic
trick god you did dirty the only tactic
connor knows oh
my god austin you fell right for it oh
now i hear you guys
in positions like that hey you're back
you know
i know and that's why i did it man i was
getting it every time put it right there
for you everyone thought you raged good
felt so good
no no i did not i'm sorry because you
were about to quit the game of chess if
you had to keep watching
right right exactly yeah so what what's
happening somebody's winning right
so they've just randomly and then
conor went for another bait he basically
moved his pawn to d6
hoping that austin would take with
knight from b5 which happened
and it was one defended piece and so
conor took it that's one
conor tactic and then he took the bishop
just now
he does see the bishop take as well it
landed itself naturally so he was down i
think nine at one point in this game
and has all of a sudden brought it back
to a winning position
guys this queen takes bishop three
squares to the right
happened last game it's the same
thing yeah i i wish austin would have
recognized
how bad that bishop being on on that
square
was for him and how useless it was
but i think he just feels comfortable
with it being there for some reason
when you play early chess there's you
just feel comfortable like i used to
feel very comfortable
pinning with my bishop on my opponent
tonight i just felt comfortable doing it
i learned later on that it's not always
good but i felt very comfortable doing
it so i would always do it
oh no oh bishop b2 does he see oh and
he's taking the queen
and what did i tell you levy earlier on
i knew that would work if you
brought the rook down eventually as long
as the presence was there
there would be a blunder i know how
these players
minds are working what they're thinking
all right because you categorize pieces
you think they're safe and then you
forget
you don't look at the board once again
and so as i predicted the blunder came
out
i've seen this game top to bottom it's
going to be a connor dub
yeah but didn't you say austin was going
to win oh well let's ignore jesus
what are you doing here glad for
christ's sake
come on i got called a couple things
just pog you all right all right pog you
pog your pog
we got it all right i was i was just
about to ask
uh how you would maximize your uh
oh boy all right ludwig put it away
tactical shot here let me see
oh my goodness yeah that's what i was
actually on god i was gonna say the same
thing i think it's
whatever the most aggressive play is is
what will be played
i think he might see rook take uh or
queen take rook here as well
uh if not oh no well it's white to move
well but i think oh don't do it
white white will probably move their
king
it's a good move though it's a good move
yeah
i gotta say connor just found like five
very good moves
in a row yeah he's due for a blunder
that's for sure
uh i think he's gonna move as either as
queen of rock that's for
sure i think he might try to bait here
well that's great oh wow he found the
best move in the position oh my gosh
that is literally it's mate i mean
you're just mating the guy queen b1 is a
mate i mean it's a buffet of checkmates
and he's threatening the bishop
what a move oh wow
don't know what austin's response will
be but i think conor sees
or in i feel like conor
might go f1 here with his
oh austin oh austin that's what i'm
worried about
i see it is that i'm not sure what
austin's response will be but i think
i'm not four
[Music]
and then you find rook takes bishop uh
that technique to winning
simplifying just getting all the pieces
off the board i really appreciate
another way
i mean checkmate in one is good but uh
you might as well prolong the game
you just know it's coming
this is crazy all the times we
had together as our lives change and
whatever
this is over it's gonna be over connor's
to win the game
[Music]
wait a minute
gentlemen how many moves will it take
him to win via checkmate
two uh three
[Music]
fourteen
that's not bad he'll probably check me
in the next stop running
yeah i don't know if he knows about the
walk down
but maybe that's what he said um
this is crazy if andrea taught him the
ladder mate right before the show and he
gets to use it and does it
stop running no take it
i think it's it's just like no take it
austin
no take the piece no
yeah what is it what are you going to do
i think he thinks you're going to do
that the king continues
no it's not it's your turn
oh austin they're debating whose turn it
is
no he definitely knows the latter but he
moved the queen to the
uh kind of the wrong square but he'll
still find it i think with my problem
is if austin goes g1
right i think conor might still go or
maybe he'll see it
okay maybe levy was right well we're on
move five now i said 14. that was not
very gracious but
wait i'm actually stressed right now i
don't know how to get you
i think he sees it oh my god i think
connor sees it
i'm scared i don't want you to kill me
and now it should be easy since the king
did not come close to the rook and the
queen he should see it right
austin yes oh connor messed up
double checking why you've made a
significant blunder
oh nice and it's on the board there it
is
oh dang it the ladder made why
oh i could have stalemated it and i just
made a blunder
i could not have stalemated no no no no
i've done it again
as long as there's other pieces that
connor undefeated
actually a pretty good thing to know
that i didn't know for a while if
there's other pieces on the board
there's really no risk of stalemate
you can kind of just experiment on how
to check and figure out what works best
for you
yes wow uh gentlemen i did not expect
that that was a great game that was
amazing that was great uh from from the
start
to the finish wow uh we have to give
hats off
let's take a quick break we'll see and
try to get uh well
one or both of them to talk to us sounds
good
[Music]
good one
and it doesn't
oh good luck thank you
i'm gonna need it can i be wagga and
dota hell no
the one chasm here for the two months
and uh rascal 49. i believe in you
yeah i don't know why i'm so nervous
though it's weird
it's not that weird i guess i'm just not
that confident
but i feel like i i have the skills you
know
say hi to the main podcast what's up
lovely hello guys
not as nervous as half of you yeah she
has more
expectations on her a couple of pamela
thank you
[Music]
carlos says you have to take off your
shirt it's in the game rules wait is the
car even casting right now
dude maymay's game was so entertaining
to watch he
is oh
karu always casts okay
you gotta do her deep breathing
techniques does mamma have deep
breathing techniques i think she has
short breathing techniques
thank you
it's called hyperventilating yeah oh
hey dog don't hang your queen that's a
good idea
you know is it a misplay if you don't
get punished for it
who knows
it's just advanced pm yeah
it's not misplaying if you don't get
caught that's cute
if it goes to blitz i think i'm done i
uh
i'm not a very fast chess player i'm
pretty good in slow
circumstances where i could take like a
year you know
can mail in my answer
take a year to to finish a chess match
but
10 minutes man
um
i'm gonna turn down the music so i can
focus a little bit more
get ready just prioritize not vlogging
if you get the blitz yeah
no hanging pieces all that
i played some old dude at the park one
time he crushed me i never played again
do old people still play at the park
i think old people probably play online
now
in new york
i don't think i've ever seen someone
play chess at the park
like ever actually ever
go to bigger cities oh chess hustlers
welcome back everybody to pogchamps
three uh spot no just skipped ahead pog
champs dude you guys
rattled me so much i forgot the name of
the entire event day three
austin connor how are you guys i'm good
you know i've been better um
just wasn't my strongest showing today
folks i uh
you know i uh i need to practice a
little bit more be honest with
you uh that was the worst chess game
i've ever seen in my life
what do you mean and i watch cutie play
over her shoulder sometimes
right well you know lud uh
it's coming from a guy where it was a
victory for me if i were to make a legal
move
and you know that's just coming into
this tournament
thinking that that was going to take me
to the next level just was
just a huge huge mess up
well austin you actually had a lead in
both games and a pretty
tremendous lead a big enough lead that
at least game one would have been called
curtains
right and game two was damn close and
then it
ended up getting you know taken away
from you with a pretty impressive
comeback from conor
uh an accidental comeback he didn't even
mean to well
i will say there were two specific
tactics that conor
or one tag that conor used twice that
ended up working out
i we like to call it the bait the bait
and take
yes so you saw this you saw this was not
by accident there were a couple times
where i did see something and i baited
him
uh you guys can see the board here on
the screen right i don't know how to use
this
app well you can just see it you don't
have to touch anything yeah don't touch
it visually with your eyes you can see
it right
no i just see you because i touch stuff
connor oh you are full kim on me right
now
yeah click click the bottom right corner
click the bottom right leave room
no no no no no don't leave the room
connor how are you choking zoom calls
yeah you just won two chess games
tech support top right corner top right
okay okay now click on the top thing
where it's blue and stuff i did it
middle top middle top middle yeah there
it is now you see it it's on the right
now you see the board on the right right
up i did it again
wait i fixed it i see it i see it i see
it i see it connor great i see it even
better
in tech support i've never used zoom i'm
not in college anymore all right so look
at the board on your right boys look at
the board in your room okay hold on can
i address something real quick this real
quick okay sure my rank at 299th
okay or whatever 299. listen i'm sorry
not all of you had to put too much in
the world i lost
alexandra botez 30 consecutive times
okay so that's why my not all of you had
to play against alexander botez in an
odds chess
match okay i that's why my score is so
low okay connor
got to he out andrea held his hand
throughout that and she let him win
that's why his score was so much higher
than mine this is awesome
can i tell you something yeah it's
better if your score is lower because
then you will have a better seed
and you'll be able to play like worse
players i know and that's what happened
here ludwig look where it got me
well that's what i'm saying if your seat
was higher there's
it's not like it would have changed
anything i guess
right that's what because nobody is even
close to this low of a ranking
so it's more so for just like the
socialness of it you wish it was higher
so you could i just wish it was higher
so i wouldn't get made fun of
i'm gonna be actually there's a really
good way to raise it there's a good way
to raise it up
by playing and winning yeah just [__]
win
i'm gonna i'm gonna shock the world i'm
gonna come back and i'm gonna shock the
world i'm gonna
teach you let us teach you something let
us teach you something right here
because you this is uh i believe this is
game two right
yeah this is game two this is beginning
of game two and then
back up one move specifically uh just to
see so you're in this position here and
uh
and austin you just played right rook
left side to b4
and you were thinking of taking that
knight maybe it was a great move all
right you're pressuring the knight which
is hanging no ludwig he he played the
move because he saw the free bishop
oh yeah so even better he took a bishop
and then you also had a free knight that
was hanging
conor does this and this is let me be
very clear the worst move
possible that's like he goes b5 with his
point
no i mean the worst move is queen g5
which would just
throw the queen but yeah but it by all
means
is is not a winning move wait wasn't a
winning move
b5 with your pawn why not
because he can just take the pawn with
his with his
knight also with rook your your knight
is hanging you can take your knight
there
right there you're leaving pieces
unprotected
uh and they can just be taken because
they're also under threat
right so you basically walked into a
man's gun
it's like getting killed by hikaru and
valorant you [__] up somewhere because
you walked into a prey
gentlemen i i would love to keep you
both on as long as possible
uh but um i think connor's zoom
shenanigans
set us back a little bit and we have dog
dog in sex
we're stalled we saw too long anyway the
point of the the lesson was
uh uh just look around the board a bit
austin
yeah and do lessons with your damn
coaches i know
sorry i had a 30 minute lesson with
alexandra and that was two weeks ago
um and i really thought i retained a lot
of information i was feeling confident
uh i was feeling real confident i would
just say play a little more than every
two weeks
yeah maybe like every other day or
something right okay i need i need to
practice a little bit more
uh who's next who do i play next uh
we'll see it should be coming in the
upcoming week i'll look i'll give you a
coaching session
awesome that's my guarantee you're gonna
coach me do you even know how to play
chess why don't you coach me
all right gentlemen
you can figure out all of your coaching
sessions with ludwig ludwig's actually
been quite sharp today
we wish you both the best connor welcome
to the show great games
austin we want to see you bounce back
let's uh i'm gonna come back
let's show you guys who's coming up dog
dog sex row
hearthstone versus fortnite who you guys
got
i don't know anything about their chess
skills have you guys coached them at all
um no i have not i mean i think dog dog
certainly has been playing a lot he's um
he's worked with half with uh
with hafu so uh he's definitely the
favorite zextro is a last minute
replacement um for i will dominate so i
think he's relatively new to the game
but i think he had like a 700 rating or
690 or something around there
um if i'm if i'm not wrong so it's gonna
be a it should be a good match
zextrow's the one that got banned from
ninja's tournament right
correct yes that's so hype i hope he
brings the same trash talk to chess
that he did to fortnite wow
that isn't that i did not know that um
yeah
yeah he won a ninja tournament and then
trash he just trash talked his opponent
and then
ninja was like all right bye
but you know he still won the money at
the end of the day and i can see he
wants to bring his talent to a more uh
like uh how do i word it more d gen
field you know the game of chess where
we get rough here you know what i mean
we're not soft oh we do
yes yes chess fans can be very rough
doesn't matter their level doesn't
matter the level of the person that
they're watching could be hikaru could
be
could be me could be ludwig could be
austin could be
you know they're gonna be critical
they're going to be real critical
talking a
heavy mess and so i i i want to see that
energy
uh but you did coach dog dog right levy
yes i gave dog dog a lesson he so his
playing style i don't think i'm supposed
to
hold anything back he's done several
lessons with several people
very solid super solid some games he
makes no mistakes
but the man told me straight up that
he's okay
losing on time because he feels as
though
if he makes no blunders time management
is not something that he you know
worries too much about that's something
that he will pick up i don't agree with
that
but he's also a he's got double the
rating of
of his opponent yeah so oh and hikaru he
plays your opening he plays knight of
three e3 b3
yeah but zextra also plays my opening he
plays the uh kings indian
like a man all right well
who we got i mean i got a roofer's extra
of course
like okay i just have to i mean he's
kind of king's indian no one else has
played the king's
indian i think in all pog champs so i i
have to i have i have
have you taught him this where do you
learn the king's indian
i maybe he watched my stream i don't
know but 86 is kind of a weird move
so i don't know so uh dog dog i was
doing a lesson with him maybe a week ago
and he told me that that a coach that
he's working with like a like a like a
guy who plays hearthstone and chess was
like very skittish wouldn't tell me the
name
uh told taught him this he taught him
knight f3 e3 d4
uh b3 bishop b2 and now he's gonna put
his c pawn up and play bishop e2
exactly did he just get coached by
forsen
i i think it was either svidler or delay
one of the two
so he said it wasn't like he also said
it was somebody rated twenty one hundred
so it was not it was delay it was delay
he said it wasn't like he said it wasn't
zelay i could have lied to you
i i i asked him he said he didn't lie so
listen i believe him
that's not how lies work man they right
he said he didn't lie lol all right one
of us is going on the record suggesting
that dog dog is a liar
uh i'm i just think he has a coach rated
2100 but
like i said is dog dog one of the
favorites to take down this event
i top four maybe top three yeah i think
it's very hard to tell because dog dog
many of the times that he's been uh been
playing he's
been with him so it's hard to judge just
how strong he is on his own
um but i think certainly he should be
for sure in the top eight um
i would say maybe around third or fourth
probably right now is what what i would
judge it at
but i'm okay but he is one of the
favorites that being said i'm extremely
impressed
impressed by zex rose opening um because
by pushing the pawn to h6 it looked like
a weird move but then he put the bishop
on e6 so the knight can't attack the
bishop
so he's showing some really good strats
here
right exactly you don't need to justify
h6
uh unless you literally are putting the
bishop here
but like i said guys dog dog is is so
solid
i mean this is an opening that's
extremely difficult to crack
so we'll see what zextrow can come up
with
i want to see ludwig playing like this i
know he's retired but ludwig if you ever
come out of retirement
i want to see this from you yeah i mean
i cracked that opening easy
i just late game levy late game levy i
mean i just don't love the right side of
the board there
for uh for for black you don't you think
it's weak
yeah it's just you know not enough
pieces
in my opinion i like to stack in a few
more
well hikaru's cheering for zextron now i
highly doubt both of these guys are on a
call with each other trash talking
so ah doubtful very doubtful for all
these reasons yeah they're not that
familiar with each other let's uh let's
see what's extra's up to
okay okay
he's
oh snuffy pushes this up
i could defend i could uh
attack that i think very focused
very good so far very very good also his
board is covering two squares
i mean his cam is covering two squares
that is crazy from a streamer
perspective
like just move the window open dude come
on
over the ads have better real estate
than his camera
push this up he defends with that
you take and then gentlemen if a piece
moves to those squares it's gone
yeah i have a question so i guess in
between
your moves i think i think i think
do you follow a line or you look at many
different lines
like hikaru for you for example if
you're playing one line because i think
that's what i would do or some early
players or beginners would do
is look at one line and stretch it far
hoping they do it
as opposed to like looking at yeah i
would say like here for example what
what the thinking would be is just how
many pieces do you attack this
or not attack how many pieces can you
capture this pawn with and how many can
your opponent recapture how many pieces
defend this pawn
yeah um so i i think as a beginner it's
more important to focus on just one line
and try to
try to calculate a couple moves then
then look at multiple moves because then
your brain just starts getting confused
okay sure
keep it simple stupid i i think dog dog
got a little bit of tunnel vision there
he played d5 attacking the bishop great
move
but then he just kept attacking the
bishop and didn't realize that
it's just two to one uh might be a
little bit of nerves he did
remember that when the knight jumped to
e4 that the bishops opened up which is
not a skill that everybody picks up on
when they're first starting out so then
he took the bishop and now well
unfortunately he's just down a pawn
right now but it's not so bad
because open king
correct well ludwig your prophecy is
it's coming true
open king you don't like it that's what
i'm telling you man don't love that
right side
yeah let's go listen to dog dog we have
we have two streams this time so we'll
get two perspectives
i think i'm gonna have to trade here
he takes maybe there was a tactic
no it's just a stupid thing on c5 is
giving him so much space now
he's better than me right now um i can
force a trade here but this thing's kind
of trapped honestly
but i don't think i can win it can i he
doesn't have any pressure
like his pieces are trapped actually
maybe i offered the trade my my knight
can't go anywhere so maybe i offer the
trade here what can he do he takes my
knight runs my pawn structure and now i
take there
it's fine yeah one thing i'll say
if i can while he's i don't see another
maybe bringing my rook out is better
here this thing's trapped
yeah i think i'd rather just deal with
it
it's annoying i think it might just be
trying to talk himself into the move
i will say it's a kind of minus one but
he's like super trapped there i think
it's a little bit so if i can just get
my rook here
be harmful though when you talk too much
to yourself i think um at this level
because i think you can kind of talk
yourself out of certain things and then
your
your brain is just spinning all over the
place yeah i think talking is less
thinking and more justifying a lot of
the time
yeah yeah so what i noticed when i was
working with with uh
with dog is that uh he
he has a lot of like he'll just say four
ideas that he has
one is really good two are okay and like
one is like not great but he never
you know what i mean like he doesn't do
the whole process he'll be like idea
that
oh but then there's also this and then
he never just goes okay that one's bad
let me think of something else cause he
might be thinking of a winning move
but he keeps on thinking yeah correct
yeah
but dog dog is down one pawn here to be
fair he is behind by one pawn now what i
am wondering is if sex wrote
like took some lessons or has done some
puzzles because considering his rating
at 665 right now
he's playing this very very classically
it's a very slow kind of maneuvering
game
with very sort of positional concepts
nothing super deep or super aggressive
so i do i do wonder
um what his preparation has been now
obviously it was last minute so maybe he
didn't have the chance to do any
preparation but if he hasn't then his
opening has been fantastic
i think even being coached by someone
like you were saying
he was being coached wait wait who was
he being coached by was that the
hearthstone was that dog though he's
being coached by the heart
dog yeah
yeah maybe just watch your stream maybe
that's the power of ikaru stream
you just watch and suddenly you play a
thousand level
hey i mean okay i mean i guess yes they
are theoretically yeah but
you don't need you don't need to like
give me that fly look i'm just gassing
you up brother
i'm just saying after i started watching
i hit plat 2.
different game however but still
learning
okay yeah
anyway though i'm kind of curious to see
how this game progresses because it's
not this is very unusual like normally i
feel like
all the pieces come out early for the
players and the pieces are coming out
very
slowly the rad33 is a great move yeah
really really good move so like i said
like dog made that mistake earlier with
e4 just miss counting but
hikar and i have talked about this a lot
in sub-battles i mean in so many things
where we watch low-rated players play
lack of space is so huge and you
you struggle like if if zaxar doesn't
play e5 will he ever
on e5's a tough move to play or e6
try to fight back in the center right
let's see
also yeah i think he did move the camera
which is one of the reasons why we had
to shift him
the the squares on his stream have
opened up saved
i'm just thinking about where my knight
goes after
and i think we're gonna take a look does
he he doesn't talk too much right
no i don't think so now
yeah he does he really doesn't talk i
mean i just unmuted his stream and he's
just
not speaking watching hikaru play chess
at point
one speed he just says takes but every
ten seconds as opposed to hikaru who
goes take stakes take six takes
prior right exactly yeah with it a
second
all right what do you you like this move
queen of five i love it it's a great
move to try and trade the queens because
he's ahead by one pawn
yeah actually i'm starting to think
maybe zextrow is um his rating he might
be underrated because
even though like he's not playing super
precisely he's not blundering any any of
his pieces so i'm thinking he might just
have not played a lot of games yet
because so far this has been fantastic
i'm just not going to push that side i'm
just going to let his pawn sit there i
think
i could push up this also good move from
dogs to play queenie
not trading the queens and he's lining
up to uh to e7
so i guess i'm attacking does that does
not address
the threat but will dog
is he just trying to hope that he
forgets it for a turn and then he can
bring his rook in
no i think he missed it i mean queenie
two you know because like he just missed
it he just missed
oh my goodness that's that's a losing
move queen f6
is a double attack oh my gosh
dog can literally get a it now as long
as he doesn't blunder the rook in the
corner he has a chance
but oh my gosh it's a hard move to find
i actually don't think it's it'll be too
hard for him to find only because
i originally saw queen f6 last turn yeah
yeah maybe the question is will he see
the double attack yeah that's that's the
harder part because i wouldn't have seen
the double attack but i do see the idea
of queen f6 uh
only as like to move away protect the
pawn guys yeah
uh dog doesn't see the rook in the
corner i can threaten one no
that'll be brutal that i don't think
it's a back rank
it's annoying
[Music]
once and then it's that was hanging oh
my god i got destroyed
wow oh my rook there yeah it's still a
game though oh
no tragedy has struck guys but the way
sex throw is
wow wow wow
i mean one of the things that i was
talking a lot about with with dog dog is
like i've been teaching all these people
you know checks captures attacks for
themselves
but at the same time it's for your
opponent too like dog
i don't know if you guys heard that
right before i don't know if we were
there yet but dog said
as he moved his work oh damn my knight
was hanging i even said that
so he saw it but in all of his talking
he forgot
and he forgot his rook was hanging yeah
yeah that's like i think that's just
like a human thing the same thing
happens in among us man
like you'll say something round one
someone's cleared and then you just
forget by round four people just forget
man we're dumb we're dumb humans if you
don't constantly reinforce
and re-look over everyone forgets what's
going on
like i like the big picture i mean i i
was enjoying the chess coverage now i
just got to rethink my own
existence and intelligence and
i look levi i'm just saying your among
us gameplay
non-existent yeah i haven't played it
yet i don't think it'd be hot
i thought look i'm just saying i'm just
saying i'd love to play with you
sometime we'll see
oh i can't tell if this is a great
gesture or you're just setting me up to
like embarrass me in front of the class
both man both okay i like it guys it's
not over because i actually think
there's a way to win this
car you thinking what i'm thinking no
g4 rook h3 rook h6 not going to happen i
i'm not feeling it for dog dog i
haven't feeling he's very demoralized
with what has happened
and again this is one thing i would say
is a lot of us we sort of say people who
we think are
favored so i think they come in with
these big expectations and if something
goes wrong it's very hard mentally to
recover from that because of course this
is not their main game
so i think the pressure as well plays a
big role
you can already tell dog dog he looks
very sort of disappointed in what has
happened
yeah i think really big rating
discrepancies because you know a lot of
these people might not have the most
accurate rating
especially if you're going into a game
with a guy that's supposedly half your
rating
and then you're losing that probably
sucks yeah but zextra is not playing
like a 655. he's
yeah he's playing like he's like 1000.
but i think the expectations going in
because he's
listed as one uh for whatever reason
whether he didn't play enough games or
whatever
uh would you know make it harder to
grapple with losing here
wow by the way great move can i just say
what a move
excellent move oh no no oh no oh no oh
no
but but if yeah he he missed it um
he was tunnel visioning the pawn but
yeah i mean there there was knight e5
the good old fork wow
you know there is like an
outside chance oh will he see a f5 here
or not right this is a big question
like if he doesn't and then the knight
gets in and starts hitting everybody in
the face
like maybe there's a chance true
plus guys don't forget it's a very
cramped position
zextrow could play rookie six
like it could happen and you just missed
that in all of that
he plays at five it's weird when he sees
and what he doesn't
i mean yeah it's very wow
and now e4 is coming with the apple is
this guy like 2 000
he's not delay or trump that's c but if
you play z4 here i'm done i mean
this guy's the champion of the
tournament it's such an obvious move
that's the thing like you push the pawn
to make the check
like it's such an obvious move that i'd
be shocked i don't think he sees it
oh you see
he's hovering his rook right now oh
wow hovered his rook for maybe 20
seconds before switching to the pawn oh
my gosh
like this is insane
wow
what i'm gonna take those strings all
right so if you move my other screen
his reign is based off so few games
that's why it's hard to tell
because rating is based off of like 10
games so it is very possible
um i think the new rating system should
be he car
plays everybody all right and one best
of two and then you
rank them one to 16.
i'll just give them that way just to
make it easier can't trust their
chess.com accounts
yeah but guys he's 660 and rapid
he's 670 in blitz
over 400 games
yeah i think what
yeah you know maybe he just leveled up i
mean because i would argue
all the players should be like two to
three hundred points better rapid shots
generally
all right so now i can um so i i don't
know
i don't know
yeah this is crazy all right i'll just
go back here and take all of his
stuff i mean look at this rookie too
just just cleaning up here just rookie
two brings the rook and that's it i mean
you're gonna take everybody
yeah well wait so it's a dog yeah poor
dog dog
wait he could have taken that's no he
couldn't have feels bad man for dog dog
well he's got one more game but
i kind of warned him not that
you would run into a juggernaut rated
665 who would
kill all your hopes and dreams but uh i
told him like his playing style is good
to get a nice looking position but that
opening that he plays
can be so unpredictable because the
opponent can do anything right
true true yeah like that's
i don't know it's well
you play for stalemate is that the plan
you're not gonna get it i mean you've
got a knight good luck
yeah no i mean it's
is there any strategy in just leaving a
piece on the board
to avoid stalemate um yeah i would say
that actually is important like you
leave you leave like uh
you leave some ponds on the board you
don't just capture all of them
um i think that is one thing that's
important as long as it's blocked or
something
correct yeah yeah as long as it doesn't
get become blockaded but we could have
it if he gets
f4 here he pushes the pawn there's
almost a draw potential
okay let's see let's see are we gonna
get it it's so close
well no because king can't move that you
can only move oh but when he moves
tonight that pawn can move
oh right yeah your only hope is to play
h3 a3 like knight c8
and d6 oh my gosh is he trying to do it
i
think he should be yeah the perfect
stale mate line
wow he's hovering his knight let's take
a look at it
hmm
oh that queen move though she didn't see
it all right
only one way yeah the only way is to
give the night up
give the night up and push the pawn
that's the only way and you can't take
either yes
i mean he's just gonna keep going yeah
this is the only piece i can move and it
always gets taken so i guess i take a
pawn
and yeah i mean he kind of
i would concede but uh
and he was just like i'm out of moves so
i'm gonna play whatever
yeah and now the problem is that he
moves his king uh right
but it's all yeah so will this extra
just go for the queen or is he gonna
well i mean let's see if that extra
spots it i mean i feel like he's
spotting the lateral movements very well
but okay but the other thing is if
zextra hasn't taken lessons you never
know if he actually knows the
checkmating pattern so he's gonna run it
yes but the thing is i don't think dog
is thinking about moving his deep
i need my pawns oh
i have all these pawn moves that i can't
i don't want to be making
because uh i'm trying to lock up all my
pawns because that's the only way you
ever steal me now he's recognized how to
sail mate or that he should still mate
oh my gosh queen f6 might happen we
might get queen oh i'm
gonna have six with stalemate on the
board it's crazy he's not using his
queen
like that is astounding there any still
made here
okay but now okay but now he sees clean
up okay let's see
the moment of truth there's there's a
lot of them
ah wow did you
bang what an interesting idea though
dude
this game 700 points or something
not 700 but 400 okay 400 yeah
okay yeah 400 points for one game dude
yeah uh it's an interesting idea though
to like
the line you should take for a stalemate
is something i've never considered
yeah there was basically at that level
of the game once it's already very much
out of reach
like around move 37 you car and i were
getting excited because you're running
out of moves but instead of knight takes
f5
you have to do it in such a way that you
don't free up any more squares from
knight c8
but yeah i think stalemates to me and i
think to a lot of players in the
tournament are like
you know a hope and a prayer and you you
kind of like you know more than make
moves that
make it happen pray for it to happen
rather than thinking of an exact line
because that's that's
i mean yeah you're pointing out could
have had a line right there
yeah but it's a little bit too much and
i and i guess at the end there was one
more thing
okay well instead of one more thing we
have uh
we have dog dog with the black pieces
now he's gotta win gotta win
oh who is this zex rogue guy i mean my
goodness
it is insane that he can crank 90s and
crank d4s
that's
uh who taught him this opening
well who taught him who taught dog g6
yeah i don't i don't actually know
yeah very very unusual opening from both
sides
oh gentlemen can i just please go on
record with something
yeah i have not been teaching the
players in this event to london
i don't know where that rumor came from
but
haven't you no i i should have seen
something following a d4 line what's the
d4 line
well i'm not saying cutie cinderella's
opening out loud okay
she's gotta play it first sure sure
actually in her opening the dark square
bishop like barely moves
hmm all right hey sorry to sully the
good name of levy
all right all your openings are pog
well that's i mean that's a stretch but
i but i do just want to say that very
few people in this tournament actually
have the london
uh in in their repertoire because we
can't have a london tournament where's
this
like right true it would just be boring
but zog is trying to fork the knight and
the bishop possibly in a move or two
you mean like e5 yeah
um i think i think ludwig asked what
what would make a more exciting opening
i mean yeah of course gambits but the
thing about gambits is that
we don't want spots where you just
prepare somebody in like six or seven
moves for some
chaos and if it works you win and if
anything besides that happens you get a
terrible position
that's the danger of gambits but gamuts
are fun you can win very fast but some
people like the
longer game no that's why ludwig
what was so does scott you were coiled
yeah that's so bad with v3
and by the way now now it's my turn to
say that this move i think kind of puts
arrests anything that some people were
thinking from the previous game because
that was a really bad move
that was a really really bad move
because now it opens the line for the
bishop to attack the brook
in the corner yeah b3 is not a move you
wanna
and by the way queenie eight look at
this guys e5 hicario you're absolutely
right
you are absolutely right
well queen e8 is a fantastic move as
well by dog
um fantastic oh and here we go he's got
it
dogs should see it because the whole
idea of moving the queen was to push the
pawn forward
let's check in on him and see if he
actually does have it
[Music]
he goes gets to run i push
it's to take i take he takes i win okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
should be crushing i'm not sure if c5 is
better first but uh he's still
thinking about other options as he plays
his move like he found
that's it nice fine
think sex is extra is walking through
the line
and should come to the same conclusion
hmm
he took so now i take
oh but this this is hanging at the end
of it by the way because of this
oh but it's not hanging okay so take
this
it's fine i need to watch out for this
diagonal but my queen is is fine also
okay
let's put this on the screen we've got
some
some happenings yeah
uh the best thing for white to have done
would have been to somehow consolidate
and and not just
go crashing forward right i mean
especially you don't want to give away
the dark squared bishop
yeah because now i think it's just um
it's just just
losing as dog said i win
so i think it's very likely that dog's
gonna win this
but this makes me wonder who's gonna be
the favorite if dog wins this game
because
it feels like zextra probably has more
experience than blitz chess
he's played 400 games
well here's the thing the rules state
that whoever has the higher
cap score right right gets the choice so
if dog wins this game cleanly won't he
get like a 99
like because he made no mistakes right
when you win in the opening your
opponent's right
yeah this is true yeah but anyway i mean
dog is doing well so i think he's going
to win this game
he's going to be up a piece here after
his next move and he's looking very good
yeah wow so strange i mean game to game
totally different
from sex kind of nervous well i think
maybe he had his opening strategy was
simpler because like
the opening dog played with white was
not in your face it wasn't very
aggressive it was just kind of
just like it was just very closed and
quiet
moving the pieces so there weren't many
opportunities to make mistakes whereas
this game is very open at the start
and we're seeing serious mistakes from
uh well from from zextro
in particular i'm kind of nervous if it
goes to like the
the armageddon because what was the one
thing you said about dog dog was that
he's down to lose on time
and that's that's like the easiest way
to lose on time is armageddon
yeah that blew my mind that lesson i
basically was like what do you mean and
he's like well
i feel i feel fine if i play a really
good game but i don't you know i just
run out of time at the end i was like
okay
because there's the there's the opposite
like i also work with scissors
scissors his first instinct is really
good as we saw from
the very first matchup of the entire
tournament playing against the guy who's
the odds favorite if i'm not mistaken
um you know grip x and but scissors will
just play a move and lose a piece like
boom like he doesn't fear blunders
they just occur and then he's like oh
wow crap i shouldn't have done that
but right dog is the opposite like we
just saw him spend how long on that move
a minute i feel like he thinks of chess
like a painting and even if it's
unfinished
at least all his strokes were good and
then and then scissors is like well
yeah i'm going to finish the [__]
thing yeah
even if it's ugly right yeah even if
it's ugly at least i finished it
yeah that is true well he's also had
like a whole month of doing speed runs
you kind of like you can't quite speed
run chess but it is
two clashing styles i was like if you
fuse that
amazing it's something beautiful
yeah so i mean this is this is very good
for dog he's doing very well i
i would say you know that that comment
about like losing on time it reminds me
a lot of my blitz games where
if i beat someone on the clock or off
i'm like well but i got this winning
position so i
i feel okay um but i think at the end of
the day it is a competition so it
doesn't matter how good
the position is it's the result that
matters so even if you create the
painting
like you've got to finish it like even
if it's an ugly painting you got to
finish the painting you can't
can't sort of just be like oh this is
going to be the next da vinci piece like
yeah that's not how it works i think
it's i think it's trying to give
yourself a little victory
where you really earned none in the
rules of chess
yeah exactly i mean this position is a
really good example of that by the way
if
if zex just plays a little bit faster
he's not going to be able to castle this
king anymore but queen a5 was a great
shock
yeah because you can't move okay
playing at le bon cloud or trying to i'm
not sure he knows what that is or
intended to do it but it's happening
now will dogs see bishop g4 it's not the
best move i mean it might be the best
move you weaken the structure a bit but
uh
it's a very natural move yeah it's a
natural move rook d8 i think is the
other natural move just bring the work
to the center of the board so i expect
one of those two
i just like armageddon it was so great
to start the tournament with an
armageddon
and and scissors came within like a move
or two of winning the entire thing
right 2-0 so huge uh
huge accomplishment from him ended up
winning that armageddon right
no he lost he lost wow okay he played
like a different person
he played ten moves and on the tenth
move went wait i only have 15 seconds
like he's just choked up panicked a bit
thought
yeah a lot and it's good but not always
okay bishop v6
let's say we can look at we can check in
with zextra to see what his comeback
plan is but
a little scared we're just gonna get
thoughts well let's hear it if there are
any
this isn't really doing anything i don't
think
like the loudest thing on his stream is
he's clicking this part like
he's doing what i do no acceptance in
this
statement to all controller players so
he's going to attack that
yeah i can't really do anything about
that what if i move my horse
oh this this this is a man after my own
heart he's he's doing the double click
yeah if you carl i think do that do you
love me yeah i do i started doing it and
then people think
i'm crazy now okay could you like try to
copy me with it
okay well i mean not quite
you know but i'm just going to double
click my mouse like yucaro and then i'll
magically be like 3100 right levy
30 you don't sell yourself short 3100
because
i mean the point is you'd be like number
two amongst my friends because right now
you're like number 60 or something
something horrendous yes yes where am i
you almost have no business talking to
me
am i like 59 then or something because
you're like top 50 probably
we chat a good amount like i assume that
obviously not
this would be weird that'd be weird to
be that low
i picked up like 40 points earlier today
i mean come on
imagine hikaru's birthday rolls around
he looks at like the invite list and
he's like oh wow
dropped rank this year huh yes you're
not coming back
oh man all right that's more motivation
than i ever needed
to go to hikaru's birthday yes so
anyway i was going to add one thing as
well about this game like since there
are a lot of people are wondering how
players can play with such high accuracy
when you look at the accuracy it's based
on how simple the moves are and so like
in this game dog's accuracy is going to
be extremely high but his accuracy is
also going to be over 90
because the moves are very natural like
bring the rook to the center of the
board
doubling the rooks it's just very very
normal so um
right so so that's that's the thing you
guys the certain positions lend
themselves to easier moves and dogs
going to win this game
and you're going to see a accuracy over
90 percent here by him as well
same as last words but it could happen i
like what will happen he just find two
good moves
hey carl he might play queen b6 and run
into c5 like
there's always these tricks and i and i
like how zex is playing this
he's doing the best that he can he's
hovering because he's done it
he's played queen v6
car you might have called it a little
bit early there oh my gosh i jinxed him
i don't believe this i jinxed him i
totally jinxed him oh my gosh
does dog dog recognize it yet okay okay
okay it's fine it's fine it's not his
responsibility
zex has to find it the second it's on
the board it's annoying enough to go
through his thoughts oh
let's bring this back i mean yeah he
immediately recognized it i think
because the moment i saw right after why
don't i just think
you started saying it's fine it's fine
it's on the board there's some stuff
it's fine by the way it's still probably
winning okay because white's king is so
open
but it's gonna be tricky it's gonna be
quite hard
this extra has a little smirk on his
face
so the reason this is tricky
like it's still apparently totally
totally losing and it's got to do with
white's king position i imagine first of
all
can you just play rook takes d3 probably
that's the move right that's a good move
yeah
now the question is a very hard move to
play yes exactly
yeah after queen c6 but practically with
the weak king on e2
oh
oh he did it oh my gosh he actually
plays rook takes d3 what a gangster
there you go all right it's very hard to
find the following moves
after this which is why i don't actually
like this voice
not if he plays that what do you mean
well he's well he took back oh you mean
okay i guess because you're gonna take
the queen there's gonna be a trade like
i i don't like it actually even though
it's objectively the best move
i don't like it well
here's the thing when his rook gets all
the way down
and then his queen gets taken he's gonna
move his rook to safety he's gonna
i'm assuming he'll see his rook is
hanging but
there's a chance he doesn't so tricky
here
he also i guess has queen b5 that's the
only move that doesn't lose a queen
or a rook yeah yeah
you say it's tricky here to me it seems
like no brainer what what what should
the line be
it feels like you should well well the
moves are the the next two moves it's
like you take the queen and then white
takes queen
that's a no-brainer but it's the move
after that for dog that's very hard to
play
that's kind of the issue and why i don't
like it
yeah you have to move it back but you're
worried about your rook you're worried
about your pawn there are a lot of
things under attack
sure can be captured by the way he
played queen b5 wow
yeah that's i mean he's he's a good
player
i love queen b5 i think it's it's a
great move he
he sees this so he saw two things can't
go queen takes and if you take then it's
a trade
uh let's listen to dog actually i'm
curious what his thoughts are does he
think he's like losing
or does he think he's okay
i feel like on ladder people would just
concede to that
is there any move that's really good for
him
it's very he can block here no
he has to trade i think
okay oh can i just take his queen now
yes
he just he just missed it he just
totally missed it
rode takes queen even bishops oh and he
still sees the [__]
okay now i can make another pin
oh beautiful oh man
almost let it go just drop that bishop
just drop that bishop nice it was fun
yeah we have the comeback and he's so
hesitant about that move but he but he
finally
didn't get my queen was he just down
yeah i i think i think after the first
game it's like it's also hard because
when you lose your first game like that
you're like you're really unsure because
the guy's 655 then you're like what what
am i dealing with and um
and so okay i like 91. i mean i think i
just take and start transitioning or
yeah let's bring it back okay i mean i
wanted to know what his thoughts were
about what was going on but now that
he's up a lot
he should be winning here
let's see we'll see at this point i'll
call the curtains all right we got a bit
of a sweat there but
i don't know if i don't know what the
biggest comebacks in pog champs and what
they've been but i feel like
minus 16 i guess minus 13 now
uh what about the game that we just saw
i don't think these players will be
doing anything
conor or austin have ever dreamed of
doing
which is a good thing for them
okay that's fair
yeah so i mean i think i think this is
going to be over though i think dog is
going to convert this pretty smoothly
here
very hard for white to attack anything
now he doesn't win on a draw which is
cool
right random thing in chess
i'm going to try to find out what the
the cap score of the first game was
i think it was like 89 percent for for
for zach's row yeah this one's gonna be
really high for dog dogs though as well
i think
like dogs dog's gonna be probably 90 in
this game i'm guessing
i made one bad move but every other move
was pretty good
oh man can you imagine comes down to
decimal points like what the machine
blurts out at you
and so then whoever had the better
accuracy between the two games gets to
pick which color they are in armageddon
yes
all right
yeah okay cleaning this up is not it's
not super challenging
as chat says that dog dog intentionally
blundered to lower the percentage right
[Music]
make it seem a little more normal
so queen down there's still a way like
there are
ways you can blunder depending on like
for example if he goes for a check here
queen c4
that's just that's gone but he's really
good he won't do that he won't do that i
know but two minutes
is true that's true the time is ticking
down for both players now the great move
queen six is fantastic let's see if he's
a man of his
actual words and if it comes down to the
wire if he does slow down
or does speed up let's see i'm curious
he said he'll
he's down to lose on time if he starts
making his moves quicker though
then maybe right that's true that was
more philosophy than actual
implementation uh in his gameplay okay i
will say
that when he told me that i yelled at
him
and i i went full russian
you know soviet coach and i was like
that that's great but it's not going to
win you the tournament you lose on time
every game and he's like i know i got to
do better i was like all right buddy
hang in there you could forget the good
old russian coaching of all right buddy
right yes it went hard there russia
okay but this is he's some counter play
here not really but
not really it's all defended
guys i should say the longer this goes
on
it could affect the caps in a negative
way for dog because
you know the engine's weird it'll be
like well you had all these wins but you
chose like the seventh best win
so brings it down maybe he's extra
thinking about all this
how important do you think it is to be
able to pick though i think it's very i
think actually it's very very important
at this level i think whoever gets to
pick and can pick white
um we'll we'll be at a huge will have a
huge advantage do you think armageddon
is a bit
unfair at this level because people
aren't so slow
i think it's unfair at all levels
honestly i think it's really clear at
the higher levels probably because it's
very favorable to black because it's
easier to defend
with having the less having one last
minute because chess at the higher
levels
is generally drawn with correct play so
i think it's probably
very favorable to block the top levels
at this level i think it's very
favorable to white because the players
aren't used to having to move very very
quickly
so i think the extra minute at this
level is crucial because the result is
going to be decisive either way so i
i think um it's very advantageous
do you still think it's better than just
best of three straight up
um best cap score gets to pick color
it's
it's hard yeah sure like
let's not forget scissors had white and
by move seven spent a minute on a move
yeah true but that's because he had his
dog in his lap and he was all chill
well but he still spent a minute on the
move okay no
dog no dog and he wins that if he marley
and me's it you know he's good
yeah but yesterday i think vincent also
had his dog hanging out with him for a
little bit so
mm-hmm
i think lottery is a dog and a cat i
remember i was i was
there was there was a lesson and there
was a dog present
we got dogs and cats around so we do
actually have those cab scores so from
the first game right so dog dog was 57.4
accuracy zextra was 87.9
which is actually a pretty high high
percentage yeah
all right but dog dogs got to be higher
than that in this game i think with the
lack of blunders
one bad move yeah
one hard to tell though
okay
but dog dog's moving pretty quickly here
he's moving very very quickly
so i i think he is not a man of his word
he is just going to play quickly and
probably convert this
victory i i just think that he broke his
bad habits
shouldn't we all right like
if you're right lovey i i do agree with
you there
no i i stubbornly don't switch off
wrecking ball and oh competitive
overwatch
we we all have things that are good no
your bad habit's not wrecking ball it's
playing overwatch to begin with
you know i've been told that i've been
told that
i'm branching out into more trendy games
like
marbles at his flight simulator
okay i think we'll get there at some
point sure
but that was like that was a worse move
right so that affects it it's it's a
good move
it's it's a good move it'll be a good
move okay
what
well if oh he's going to win the game
but he ruins he's going to ruin his
percentage with that move
he gives up the queen for the rook so he
has a bishop knight and he's going to
win
but the computer in terms of accuracy is
going to hate this move which means that
he's probably not going to get
the choice so it's a great move but it's
not a great move
interesting this is also where like post
game analysis
is tricky since the engine will then
tell you
oh this is a horrible move two question
marks you're like but what's the problem
i mean if this happened i would have
still won
makes it easier right
well he could have taken the queen
ludwig but then black recaptures the
rook so
like he's gonna lose either way sure but
i guess what's the goal of not taking it
hoping that you can make a check with
the rook i guess okay guys i have a
question
if if he plays rookie one is is dog
gonna take
is he gonna be really a man of his word
is he taking
and force the exchange of the queen for
the rook yeah maybe
he's got to move a little bit quicker
though he's getting down to about one
minute here
i told you he thinks he's been thinking
over 10 seconds every move
which according to my mathematicals like
what
right yeah definitely true oh so
yeah his score is ruined right yes yeah
yeah because he ruins his percentage
because even though what he played is
good from
on one hand it's really bad on the other
hand and now
i think he now should just make the
queen yeah you will
be like he's doing the walk that you why
are you doing this walk
it is a thing where you walk towards the
queen and then you realize you're not
gonna make it and then you go back but
it's too late
any of those three moves yeah and some
insight into the mind of uh of a newer
player here
uh your players do it all the time and
and it doesn't make sense because you
could just count it out and recognize it
but instead you're like oh shucks it's
like it's like you know when someone
holds the door open for you
and and you pretend to jog towards it
you don't feel rude
but you're not actually moving that much
faster it's like that
you're faking doing something good
that was like odd that was like very
specific i
i don't go outside much in new york city
i'm sure you've been there
in new york city so maybe they do no we
don't really we slam if anything we
don't really yeah
slam the door and hold it closed
i am i'm a little worried that the dog's
play is all over the place
and there is an outside chance somehow
we gotta still make
the checkmate yeah well they're only two
moves for white so one move gets
checkmate the other one keeps the game
alive
okay checkmate in one are we gonna see
it does he see it
on f2
there it is wow very nice wow that is a
clutch comeback
uh we will have armageddon we're gonna
review this game i think we're going for
a short break we're gonna put
i think it's dog dog cutie cinderella on
the screen and then we'll come back
next game decides who wins sounds good
uh do i get to choose why because your
higher seed
oh easy i'm choosing white it's never
going to end in a draw
okay never ever just remember yeah
i think dude i'm gonna hang so many peas
he's better than i thought he would be
what the heck yeah but you're also
playing
dude i kept getting forked on my
freaking thing
you know yeah when you're winning all
you have to do is improve your pieces
right 30 accuracy pro player by the way
you were 60 oh i was 60 that wasn't he
oh yeah i was black
oh my god i got fork that was the worst
experience of my life
guys oh and you go to hold on i need to
go live chess
sorry wait wait wait put me back in
coach are we against accuracy not
raiding okay
yeah oh
i don't know i i'm just going to stay on
live chat and i'm going to put me in but
yeah
just either way you got this i don't
know
if your clock hits two minutes we make
moves yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna blunder
so hard
wait why is it oh you took off email
only during the thing
you play faster than your opponent make
sure your time is above two minutes
okay oh my god
okay
oh i'm so bad at time man
i haven't played enough chess oh i get
to choose
hell yeah white that's
the five minute one
no increment oh my god
box op
oh why the rock running the forks oh all
right we're gonna just play normally
we're just going to jam stuff
he'll run out of time before me
oh he left the chat all right guys
uh emote only mode soon soon soon
but here accuracy picks he picks it said
that that i picked if they asked me just
now
oh i can't believe i threw the first
game i feel so bad
dude my my end game is just like make as
many queens as i can
[Music]
welcome back everybody thank you for
your patience tsm
xexro and dog dog finishing their mini
match tied one to one and the total cap
score was very close
but it goes to dog dog and he shows is
the
white pieces i yes the white pieces
these chosen white pieces
also love you never seen star wars love
he's never seen star wars love he's
never seen star wars
sorry continue love yeah i was that was
the next thing i was going to
yeah i was going to ask the chat then i
realized that they were misbehaving so i
think they're an emote only right now
uh they can't tell me but yeah i've
never seen that insane
he said he was playing chess but then he
karu seen it what do you say
you played a little more chess than
hikaru has it is day
hikaru made time that's fair
that's fair levy like literally everyone
on this planet has seen
game of thrones and star wars i haven't
seen game of thrones either
wow wow right now
half thor let's just get you a room
we'll give you guys a chess set and a
battle axe
oh we're in it yeah we we we have a
chess set and a battle axe so we got
five minutes for dog dog four minutes
for zextra i have publicly admitted this
on my stream never in front of like 30
000 people
uh but yeah uh never i had to call you
out i had to narc
i admittedly i did snitch on you you did
i mean
you know everything that said off air
but that's okay now i know
now i know never say what i tell you off
air all right it's
really personal let me please so if it's
a draw what happens
enlighten me if it's a draw black wins
the game because black starts with one
last minute on the clock
yes okay the white has to win the game
oh but dog dog doesn't take that free
pawn on e5
e5 was hanging to use the common phrase
oh my goodness yes those of you that
watched so many weeks of coverage it's
still hanging by the way
it's still hanging yeah but see this is
the thing you've got a guy that's just
as slow as a tortoise i mean no
disrespect
but look this makes me happy that he's
going slow because he he might be a man
of his values
right true but then he will lose
levy i want him to lose if he says the
phrase
all right that i will play slow and i
will lose
even if it you know even cost me the
game i'm playing at my speed then
do it man do it do it and then and then
look foolish and then change let me ask
you a question then
obviously i should watch star wars but
if i'm a man of my word i said i never
watched it but i never said i wouldn't
you think i shouldn't watch it i should
just go down now not seeing it at all
some people have a personality trait of
having not watched something you know
what i mean
they like they liked it but like i think
you just brought up casually because i
you know it just came out
cause i said you sound like anakin
skywalker but no one's like some people
are like
i've never watched star wars and i'm
never gonna like they
they yeah then fine don't oh whatever
all right i'm not that much of a douche
okay but let's
great no no uh look as as long as you
don't put that that you
you want to be a character of a show in
a dating profile then i think
it's all it's all fair game uh craziness
is unfolding on the board the players
are equal in time this is bad for dog
dog
this is just this is bad yeah he already
lost his minute advantage and now he
also has to win the game so that's like
right
and there's no add much better though he
is much better to be fair
of a player you're saying or oh in this
position i guess
white is much better but yes the time i
think that's what i would say is i was
trust when you're playing with white
that extra minute is really really
important sure
it's it's let's put it this way he he's
got a much better position but it's
really tough to figure out
yes exactly like feels like watching the
band from you know in titanic the band
that just plays
that's what that's what dog dogs like
yeah the ship's going down but he's
doing his thing it's hard to watch
but you just need to see it happen yeah
oh my goodness he had a full minute time
advantage
he's down he's still doing well though
he is no his position is great but like
is he doing well enough that he can win
in the next two minutes and fifty yeah i
would say he needs a big mistake from
zextra in the next like four to five
moves if there isn't a big mistake by
black here then i think he's in really
bad shape
yeah before's a good move
a move like knight before is gonna make
dog think
and he's thinking and it's coming true
he's thinking about the bishop
which is a good move but it's a risky
move too yes
so now sex has to find something is it a
good move for v8
bishop three just go back right well
he's gotta find it he might say okay
he's just oh
wow that was good that was fast this is
crazy
i don't like that but it's it's fair
game at this point
yeah i think it's anybody's game here
this is crazy
over the 20 seconds are getting away
from him and he's got to move first
constantly
so now it's 25 that's not a bad that
might be the best move on the board but
he found it in
15 seconds yeah very very good move
yeah it's very this is anyone's game
here anyone's game
oh okay not a bad move
wow but dog dog finds knight f5
oh my goodness
now he should take with the pawn here
will he he does
oh dogs gotta do something wow he is
completely winning but he's only got two
minutes to figure it all out
yeah and this is this is where it's very
critical that he finds the moves quickly
now the question is will zextra
understand that he needs to use his
knight
on the side that's doing nothing and
bring it back into the game this is the
other question here
oh yeah so here's what i'm going to say
my assessment is
x-ro is definitely not 655. he's
probably closer like
i would say 900 level he's definitely
not 655.
he he doesn't blunder much he really
doesn't he just missed a backwards night
move that takes a piece but
yeah like his blunders are like small
they're like mistakes but they're things
that like unless you're really good
you're not you're not necessarily going
to spot right away and it's just like
it's
it's impressive to see it it actually is
it's like for how fast he's
i mean he had 400 games right he had 400
blitz games yeah yes
i think he's i guess used to moving fast
without playing like an idiot
yeah because i think that's the thing is
most these players who are new what they
do is they move really really
quick if they have to move really
quickly they make blunders so it's just
the patterns aren't normal you're not
used to having to move and so the
instincts aren't there
and it's like zextra here he plays a bad
move by moving the knight but he just
retreats it he does not panic and he
just brings it back
to the square it was on before yep
okay so now there's now there's some
tricks with the the knight jump to d3
yeah but i mean i oh my goodness yeah i
know i expected it because
zextra has been been jumping all over
the board with that knight already
like he went to c2 then he went back and
now he goes the other way
it's a piece that i expect him to sort
of be tunneling on at this point
oh my god i think zextra is going to win
this
he's got a good dog dog has a 58 seconds
i'm really nervous for him
yeah i'm very nervous here too because
here's the thing like like for example
like
what's what what's there to think about
oh he doesn't see that the night is
hanging i don't think
oh i don't think he realizes he can take
the night with the rook here
oh no oh no i don't think he realizes
boom the night
it's because the night's only been safe
oh no
thinking oh yeah oh no i left it hanging
i'm so not used to it
you can go here oh everything's falling
apart chat
everything fell apart can't even take
that
everything fell apart
oh that was hanging
that was literally hanging that was
hanging that pawn is huge i'm just
trying to go faster but
this is a fork apart everything is like
a fork apart it's freaking me out
oh scary i have 18 seconds left
the win that's diagonal spooky
yeah we can i mean we can we can
probably bring it back we we popped in
right as uh as the critical moments were
happening but the thing is that
he started the game up a minute he's
ending the game down a full minute
clutch he just hung the rook but zextra
missed the rook
but he has no time i guess yeah this
point doesn't matter right
yeah like zex is focused i mean he is
playing
with jester rook i can't imagine he'll
be able to find no
i i love how many night moves he's
played he's like he's moving that night
every single
oh i didn't play enough rapid why didn't
rapid
whatever 20 how many moves no it's like
40 of the 40 moves like halfway just his
night
so guys we uh we will get uh either one
or both of the players
uh for an interview uh congratulations
to zex
late substitute i guess not so late but
uh wins gets two points for the
standings we'll take a quick break get
everybody uh
loaded for the uh interview
[Music]
i don't know if scissors lost did he win
i don't know if scissors lost oh why
would you show mine that's so
[__] up i wasn't ready why would you
do this to me i'm clearly leeching off
of you guys i don't have anything
planned
that's so rude everyone act cool
we've been practicing all morning
do they believe it oh no stop don't act
like this
hi guys nice to meet you i have a dog it
makes me special have you seen anyone
else play with a dog on their lap
probably not i've been practicing a lot
i am i bought a checkers board and it
didn't help me
and then i tried to play with hans but
it just ended up in me yelling at him
and then i tried to play with levy and
it ended up with me yelling at him
and then i tried to play with nemo and
it ended up with me yelling at her
so i decided to quit chess and become a
full-time um
what i play i play backgammon
i play backgammon because my coaches
have let me down
um but we're gonna see how we do today
because we're trying to
win money mostly trying to win money
we're poor we would like to move out of
this closet
um we're going to leech as much as
possible so it's so nice to uh
so nice to see you guys here i would i
would i would appreciate if they would
uh
so i don't know why he's yelling there's
a man yelling at me
i would prefer if i wasn't on the camera
right now i wasn't ready
i simply wasn't i haven't taken my xanax
this morning
i'm ill prepared miss kim quit um that's
because he got the blackmail i sent him
i've been doing that to most of my
opponents you guys want to watch this
this is actually interesting
so i'm going up against tf blade today
and uh something you should know about
him is we have a little bit of history
and it uh it goes like this so the funny
thing
about revenge guy is you think
that you could save me until the last by
saying
what was that oh
right so this dumb [__] thinks he can
backstab me
he thinks he can keep me around to
backstab me you know what i have to say
to that
hey thanks for keeping me for the extra
views you're still a beta
wow
thanks for keeping me around for the
views to go up very smart of you
good job buddy cutie cinderella chose
host
[Music]
it's not really funny don't say rude why
are somebody saying rude
it's because you're intimidated by women
okay it's not
that's not my fault it's it's his fault
that he didn't give me the full host
because i would have if i would have
if i would have won the full host i
wouldn't have come back to chess i'd
have no reason to play against him
but you know we do have a host online
he's gonna add me to his auto host
if he loses to me he has agreed to that
for sure it's and written
uh written blood he wrote it with his
blood we both
we both did that um it says the show
starts in zero seconds so chess.com
i still don't know why i'm on your
channel i don't have pokemon cards to
open
nobody i didn't i didn't know uh
i i i don't know what to talk about you
guys can see my game plan today
if that's helpful for the new people
that are here
my game plan is simple i'm going to uh
i'm going to seduce his father i'm going
to become his stepmother
i'm going to steal his college fund and
i'm going to make him poor i did write
this all down
this was very important to me to have a
plan if you write it down
then you at least know kind of like a
path of direction
uh oprah always told me that if i write
down what i'm going to do it's more
likely to come true
um so i do i hope i can accomplish these
things today
it might take more than a day um i have
gone to his channel a few times
i've talked a lot of trash i told him
his mother didn't love him
uh he didn't seem to like that he banned
me
welcome back everybody we are lucky
enough to be joined by two members of an
amazing
match welcome zach's welcome dog dog i
will start with uh with yousex
uh what are your what were your
impressions of the day how
did it your expectations versus reality
uh did not expect to win uh i got
really lucky i'm not gonna lie yeah yeah
that's about it what is that no bring
the same fire you had in fortnight
sexual come on it's almost like your
dick or something what's going on
listen yes we're hard don't go soft on
us
i i can't i can't not again not again
uh well hey you you uh you've definitely
played very well today
uh far past your level we were saying
that you know whatever level you were at
i think probably primarily based off
your blitz game is not accurate for
rapid
games uh hikara was impressed
for sure if carve you wanna what do you
think he's there yeah i was just gonna
say
um in general did you do any preparation
i think i know that you were playing in
a fortnight tournament
uh over over the weekend uh so i assume
you didn't do a lot of preparation but
if you did do any preparation
i mean was there anything that you
prepared for this event so i started
playing chess like
a month ago and i learned the london
system
in the indian defense and then i've just
uh played with that but i haven't played
chess
in like the last two weeks why'd you
pick the indian
um i don't know i was just watching
videos saw it
was it perhaps a video from mikaru uh
was it hikarus it might have it said the
indian system was good against the
london system then i learned the london
system so then i would know how to play
against if someone
played it that is literally like a
starting package of openings
so yeah i think i watch your video
me yeah well let's
see
the 10 minute chest opening video my man
my man knows
oh my gosh all right well then listen i
gotta i gotta pass this on to dog like
that dog
yeah we gotta we gotta get faster i know
i'm so slow
i need like uh i need like an hour levy
told us at the start that you had a
philosophy that was you don't care if
you lose on time is this
true okay i didn't while i was
practicing because i didn't want to make
bad moves
that was it so when i was practicing i
just never wanted to make a bad move
and then yeah but then when the time
actually comes and i start stressing out
especially like during a tournament i
thought i'd get fast enough but
i don't think i was there yet i needed
to play more does this loss hurt
less because it was on time
uh no i mean i messed up a ton i kept
getting forked i
like i wasn't confident in like where i
was moving my pieces it was just
it's kind of a mess all over the place
um he played a lot better than i thought
he would be like he was
he was uh not leaving any pieces hanging
and stuff like that so he did really a
really good job
yeah my question was going to be when
have either of you looked at the rest of
your group
and do you have any you have any targets
i have no idea i don't know how that
works okay
all right so you're just going to show
up and and then you know win
london kings india and spam it yeah
you're not going to play for two weeks
watch one levy video and then beat the
top rated player it's just how it goes
man that's just what happens when you
watch one lovely video that's 10 minutes
long
i i think it has more to do with the
player you know i feel like he's he's
just
to be fair i didn't watch your video
levy so it might have it might have been
the video
well you see where you messed up now you
see where you messed up you will adapt
and
analyze i know what i'm doing right
after this yeah
boot him up put him on a playlist i
appreciate it
uh no that that is obviously that's very
cool well look
we we have your your other group c
competitors coming up
uh you guys can scout out their openings
we will be just this critic i think
we're going to be a bit more critical of
this match i think you guys are
the cream of the crop in group c so best
of luck to both of you uh any
any call outs any any trash talk you
want to throw on the screen or all good
vibes here before we move into matchup
three
yeah wait there it is what is this x-ray
come on could bring it here
oh no no mine was definitely a fleek i
didn't deserve to win
oh he's become soft with the game of
chess the pawns are rounded about
all right all right well hey gg boys
great games great games
all right um yeah well dog if you if you
had any
any any other thing but i guess gigi
will will do it best of luck to both of
you
uh i don't exactly know who else you're
playing but they're about to be on the
screen so
stick around get a scouting report
let these guys go and uh
cutie cinderella versus mr t
i have blade um yeah i was gonna i was
gonna add one thing though that
that that to me kind of was a little bit
striking
um which was that to me it was a little
bit striking that it felt as though
uh when i saw zextra playing his play in
a way the coordination of the pieces
it it sort of reminded me a little bit
of nate hill from the original pog champ
so i don't know if that's just like a
fortnight thing or what it is but the
coordination of the pieces it reminded
me a lot of um of nate hill
specifically which i thought was quite
interesting
oh you mean you mean uh the way zex was
playing
yeah he was just kind of coordinating
the knights and the bishops it just felt
very
it just it reminded me a lot of nate
hill like nate made many many mistakes
but the one thing that i noticed was he
was very good at kind of coordinating
like one or two pieces together to try
and attack and
that's what this match reminded me a lot
of
yeah maybe they talked maybe they had a
little i i i
look if all he did was watch this is did
i hear him correctly he said he picked
up chess a month ago
watched one video on the london
and then and then the defense he played
and then hadn't played for
two weeks yeah that's what he said
that's the words that came out
he's reformed and that's what happened
or that secret trash talk and he
actually grinded his ass off
but either way that's crazy yeah
well i think it listen it it does
ultimately have to do with how well you
retain and then how well you implement
because if he said that he and he was
truthful that he didn't play in two
weeks
he was really sharp today for a big
chunk of these games
so yeah yeah and i saw a chat going
crazy saying i did ultimately teach
somebody to london indirectly
i never coached the man but he watched
the video and that was really the whole
point of those videos he
he referred to them as like 10 minute
openings it's like people don't have
time to watch these one-hour lectures i
don't ludwig when you went on chess
youtube
sorry wait back of a second you guys he
said he started playing one month ago
right
correct but he's played 400 blitz games
that's a lot of time like that's a lot
of time so okay
i'm not sure i believe that i think he
definitely
underplayed the amount of uh effort he
put in
which i don't know if you know that
makes it feel like he did better but
uh either way he he's definitely put in
some time into the game of chess
and uh and levy's 10-minute guides
are the key i was going to ask ludwig
what what what on
youtube do you watch chess wise i know
you only have chess
so uh yeah well chess content that's
chess content is great
and my favorite part is when it's two
and a half hours right
and i watch one on oh gosh
what was it perhaps the berlin and then
it's a lecture hall
and then a kid walks in halfway through
and they have a little back and forth of
the teacher and the child
about how you shouldn't show up late or
something it was great i mean it was
great because sometimes
melatonin doesn't work and you know you
gotta watch something
yeah that is primarily
chess on youtube sadly uh what is what
is what is what is the path like what is
the
cause you know if you're trying to get
good at super mario 64 there's guides
laid out and you
have it all on youtube what is the path
for a chess player is it just
person to person you just have to know
someone
like to train with somebody you mean to
train and get to a higher level
is it more common to have a mentor than
to just look at guides and be
self-taught
because most online esports are all
yeah actually what i would say with that
is um
since chess has been around for for way
too long as
as we all know um prior to like if you
go back like 20 years even
it was very much you had to have a
mentor there was always someone who
guided you
the whole whole way but now i think with
it with not the internet even but just
like the amount of information everyone
has
access to i think you can get very good
being self-taught and i myself
i'm not completely self-taught but a lot
of what i learned past a certain point
was sort of just me looking at various
uh
sort of opening guides and sort of
looking at games top top grand masters
played so you can definitely get quite
good now
even even on your own i
don't mean to interrupt a serious
discussion with an even more serious
point
we have off liftoff
tf blade we have the wgm we have a cutie
cinderella
she's a is this a she's a women's grand
master is that what i'm seeing here yes
which so i guess the lesson that she did
with chiu
aka nemsko was her teaching qiu
considering that they have the same
title
yeah that's that's interesting how
impressive she got i guess i
did not sign this is not good though
this is the same
check in with her real quick because i
hear her yelling a lot i'm sure it's all
good things let's just see
mommy's hair you and your homies
okay we're fine perhaps a war cry right
that's what i would do that's what i
would that's also what i would do
yeah okay
that was good that's a that's a no one
i don't know if i would have described
him in the same way but backwards
backwards yes yes yes yes pab is
definitely just
okay coolio calm down all that levy told
me was stonewall but backwards and i
said to levy i said no
i don't know what that means please help
and then he said watch this youtube
video or something and you'll understand
and of course i didn't do that you can't
expect me to do that why would i do that
i'm not gonna watch a youtube video i
have i'm busy okay
chat everyone just relax okay this is a
hundred percent
we're just anxious we're being stressed
haven't you guys ever heard the saying
just don't be
stressed we will be fine let's get our
musical well before my
uh i lose all of my uh students
and prospective students as well yeah
why why were you such a bad teacher that
that she she uh she didn't understand
the stonewall what happened
right right so actually the conversation
was very interesting
she said uh i don't like the stonewall
when i play with the black pieces
because it confuses me everything is
mirrored
and i said okay here's some other
opening ideas
and she said great but now she's playing
well she's not playing the stonewall i
don't really i don't really know what
this is
i can't really sign off on this um but i
just want her to get her bishop out in
castle and then i think we can we can
talk
sure what is this opening call that
occur it's kind i mean from black it's
i don't know from white it's a london
system again usually like the way it
works some openings are
named after the white sequences and some
are named after the black sequences
and then once you have the opening
selected whoever whichever side like
came up with the idea then there are sub
variations so like
you'd say like the london defense is
what white played and then black
responds like a king's indian or some
some some sort of side variation sure
should we should we pop in on uh our
competitor
grand master tf blade let's see if he
knows the same chess terminology what is
the ph actually i'm gonna do this pap
correct
i've never tried it before but amazeball
very different vibe
[Music]
like this position should be good for me
but yeah
let's just see what happens in the
trades
force has to move either back this this
guy talks like every european
master ever chilling i thought he was
american well now i can actually
start moving up to i thought he's
american too i don't think he's american
africa
and then do it there's a good spot to
i know you
all that puzzle grinding that tied up
[Music]
game
as this matchup is no joke no it's very
close so far
i think he's hovering the exact move i
think
oh
[Music]
look i'm getting smarter watching his
stream the piano interstellar is going
really hard
dude my bishop
[Music]
here did he say that he was the
psychopath
psychopath we're scaling she was the
psychopath looking for a trade
question isn't he very actively looking
for the trade here
yeah i don't know how the psychopath
call works
but i assume it's never on yourself
true okay fair
all right let's bring it back let's
let's analyze this position there's
actually a lot to unpack
yeah it's very strange like because it
was winning out of the opening
opening phase white was up the pawn but
tf blade gave back this pawn
on e5 he left upon e5 hanging beauty did
not hesitate to take it back so
materials balanced
um i don't know who i would prefer here
i think both players have chances
very balanced i thought you were going
to say both players have terrible
positions but
i like that's a better no this
is this is actually quite complicated
because the white king is castles
the white's king is safer than the black
king so no matter which way you castle
the king
you've advanced the pawns in front of
your king there are a lot of weakness if
you go to the left
then then left or right uh you push b5
you push g5 that's the one thing you
don't want to do you don't want to push
your pawns in front of your king the
pawns are the piece
pieces that guard your king so well when
you castle it like white's king is very
safe
just the three pawns on their original
squares they just guard the king very
nicely
i'll be very impressed if i don't see
a pretty big blunder i think
we've seen two very different games
today austin versus connor
and then obviously the game we just saw
his extra dog dog i think this is
somewhere in between
not as chaotic as austin uh and conor
but
i think it'll have flashes from both
sides
uh that has i don't think's really come
out yet no one's made something
incredibly dull but i feel like this is
a big moment
will will cutie move her knight
back and just she sees all the squares
she's like hovering over everything
i hate what she does it bothers me that
she does that she will grab a piece and
never look at the rest of the board and
then hover it over every position
which is like a crazy thing to do
because at any point you could just like
the thing that i did and you guys might
not know this right
is i sent him a ton of questions
this is free no it's not don't do that
and you're going to levy said
something that was very very important
he said
it's gonna go bye-bye pretty soon [__]
[__] get money and i don't think i
can do that
in any of these cases okay yeah that's
sort of the problem i'm just going to
ignore that
bringing the knight back like cutie was
trying to explain it
i tell him something you should always
remember she's got a one minute time
advantage so
i don't think this will go to time
i have a strong feeling about it you
think you think something else happens
i don't to go to time i feel like the
game
needs to be relatively balanced and
mistakes need to not happen too
frequently right
and i don't think that'll be the case
uh by the way the last move that blade
blade played it gave right night an
escape route right
yeah exactly the pawn covered both
squares on the side and towards the
center
yeah yes exactly this is not and she
knows some i mean she's
she knows some checkmate patterns like
she could line the queen up
and go for h2 no this is still
so complicated anyone i've ever talked
to
my lowly lowly you know 200 levels oh
no oh no what were you
saying i'll just say the only advice
i've ever given was
just look for checkmate because i think
that's something that most people don't
do
is maybe they just think about you know
principles and advantage and position
all that
and they never think of an attack plan
and
even if it's not the best plan you can
still just win off that
uh if your opponent doesn't defend
properly
very true yeah
okay so this move knight d1 was
fascinating from from blade so he just
saw that it was gonna be a trade
now she has to spot that the queen is
hitting the pawn she's kind of a weird
spot right now she's trying to
figure out what the best game plan here
is um
a g4 yeah very exciting game though very
balanced
after those mistakes in the opening it's
gotten back to positions very very
very balanced for both sides
i'm kind of scared do you think we're
gonna see a big blunder in the next move
or two
i no no no it's just you know
it's like i'm watching my student play
and you know cutie again
yeah that's why i'm so scared
there's a check that i know
but i don't remember it i don't remember
it
[Music]
there's a check that i remember levy
told me if i go here
and i do here that is illegal that's
something
but it's the opposite side so i don't
remember how to do it because i only
remember the normal side
but i don't know how to do it on this
side normal slide yeah this this
actually is the right side
what was that what was that what do you
take what was that but
oh i don't care i don't maybe this idea
of
mating wasn't the best idea we don't
care about pawns right well what's he
looking for my version of it
uh he can't do anything with that no he
can't see she didn't have
a uh a semblance of it i should say
uh i'm gonna do this that seems fine
yeah it's pretty pretty rough though
he's up one
so he's gonna go here and then i'm gonna
go here and then he's going to have to
go
analyzing the position i think
he's just up one pawn she scared him he
ran away he moved his horse oh duck so i
would take his horse before his pawn
that's what a smart person would do
right and then he's going to go here wow
and then that's hanging so i go there
and that's math this is safe i like that
she's recognizing the hanging pieces
um right he moved that which is spooky
i don't really know what he's going to
do with that but i want to bring this
here oh very nice move
she's very offensive which i think is
good for her
[Music]
like i don't think she's ever thought
here that's hanging worried about the
queen on h5
right and that's important yeah just
looking looking away
yeah i agree
he what's this can i get anything with
this
no if i go here can i get anything i
could get that
oh hey look at this what's he doing with
that he's going to take that
i don't care okay wait so if i go here
that's fun because then i go here i
don't care
my channel and that's why i win the game
everybody loves a check that's not
uh oh i don't i don't hate it i think
it's
okay now we have to think if i go here
why did that move sharper
just that you didn't care you're there
and then i i win this i don't care
sure take it that was correct come
through oh no
no no not the best man oh my god
imagine if i win yeah let's try to let's
put this up on this might not happen
if i had the open king there was that
was the big problem
more than anything else uh it was it was
queen takes h5 is actually still a game
she finds a couple of very nice moves
uh but i think on rook f1 yeah black's
got to focus
a bit more on defense
yeah yeah and i think she has been very
offensively you know
minded yeah this entire game but it can
pay off if she's able to find
a way to mate before tf blade does
um so i think you know i think most
people
are prone to specking defense at earlier
levels
and so if you spec offense and it's you
have somewhat of a congruent plan
then maybe you just pull off a win let's
uh let's see what blade is up to because
let's see if he's converting this
properly
yeah this is piano music
sadness and sorrow i believe dude okay
so there's a way to actually move the
king i was about to go for it
fine kind of shouldn't it just be it's
just a discovered check
this one's unpredicted too right there's
a second check after that that's good i
have a look up
oh i've never used this rook before and
this one's under attack
as well if she moves it like anywhere
except
in these scores
like how the existence of a rook
surprised him well i mean
that one's dead anyways he's trying to
create the uh the ladder again
basically with the brooks on the towards
the end but cutie correctly blocked
most depressing song to listen to okay
oh this is so good
oh no
this is from like a game room with a
bishop
it's from naruto all right this is a
perfect spot for me i think
as long as i don't still mate it should
be fine
there's nothing to do
[Music]
i just heard qdl's stalemate boys time
for stale mate
right that's
i mean i think we can do a checkmate
without it at this point the song is
is quite fitting he said we can do a
checkmate without making a queen that's
what he said
that is a checkmate with the rook and
the king is that his true technique
that is a gangster move he might fail
but he's actually doing it i mean the
madman
hangout six is chuck made in one isn't
it
oh we patiently await he didn't spot
that one but
okay oh i'm trolling so hard
that was not it we have time it's okay
it seemed really cool i can't believe i
just did that oh my god
don't make it threefold though there
could be a repetition okay this time you
should be
it checkmate no there could be a
repetition i should know you have a
place down to
does she have to claim it doesn't auto
claim this allowing the trick
to claim it trips he's working very hard
but he's not
[Music]
wait why is my rook not there i thought
it was there's entire time
we're actually hitting look at this
what is happening here
[Music]
he's got this really weird setup let's
make sure it's protected quick
don't play it don't don't don't he sees
it though oh my gosh
finally my god wow i think i missed that
checkmark like 20 times over hey brute
forced it
i i mean what can you say that was uh
that was a bit of a flex sure definitely
a bit of a flex there with the uh
with just the rook and king uh but
definitely a winnable game for cutie
and i think at one point where you saw
it show the line that
could have been right so it's like that
position where there was a double check
yes i'm going back uh it looks like a
round
move 32 right so here there's rookie one
which is a double check
so white cannot capture the rook because
the king isn't an attack from both
pieces so you can't capture either piece
um and the move you have to play is you
have to move your king up one square
yup to h2 only move by the way if the
pawn was back it would be mate
right but now there's an amazing move
you can move your bishop down to g1 with
another check on the king
that the king has to move because it
can't capture the bishop because it
regards it
and then once the king moves then black
just captures the rook and black is a
rook and a bishop and white only has one
rook so black is ahead by one bishop
yeah a very very nasty combo there but
again checks
so the the reason this check is really
hard to find is because you play rookie
one you go that doesn't do anything just
take my rook but you forget that there's
you know two attacks
all right game two well as we say to
beginners one thing you should do is
always look for checks
because it could be checkmate is that a
thing
like you just happen to get checkmate
after a check yes
that's a cool rule that's a cool rule i
like that
maybe one time you'll bake it you know i
do think she's more comfortable playing
white right okay so i hope she doesn't
freak out now because the move that you
are supposed to do here i did tell her
that
uh okay that's that's that's totally
okay see she was playing the stonewall
early on and by the way great rating can
i just say
what a perfect rating she has yeah
i mean the memes write themselves uh i
should just tell both of you
hey carl was that with you or was that
with no that was
covering your games there was a guy in
the chess.com game chat as we were
watching hikaru's game
and his name was sad life so
his profile picture was saj and every
rating he had was 777.
and impressive i think we gifted him a
diamond membership i think that's what
we did
so okay so what's what's so
are you a big big fan of the civil war
what's what's your reasoning behind uh
behind
teaching duty to play the stonewall no
no no
no i'm not a no i don't i don't i'm i'm
good
no war is is the best for um
stonewall jackson i mean that's what
it's named after i don't know who it's
named after
uh but what i will say is that she
seemed
aggressive both on the board and off and
i figured we would get a good attacking
repertoire
with oh and i see sag like in the chat
right now by the way so shout out to
satchlife
i figured she'd like to attack and she
checkmated some people in like 15 moves
with you know this kind of crazy attack
but
when she doesn't get it off the ground
yeah
stuff like this happens and i did tell
her not to play that move ever so it's
good to see it
being implemented it's only upon the
levee if she's gonna blunder it's better
that she blunders pawns as opposed to
bishops and knights and rooks
true look out there i'm sure i'm sure at
one point tf blade will return
i i i tend to agree actually based on
the first game is that you're going to
see mistakes from both players
i think that's a pretty safe assessment
who do we want to listen in on
uh look let's let's listen to cutie
first and then move to tf blade a little
later in
oh [__] me
fair enough
okay he castled oh [__] the only way i
know how to win this is with my bishop
and my bishop's
gone oh no
i only know how to do it with the bishop
this is the wrong color bishop
[Music]
[__] i'm gonna let all the women down
susan b anthony margaret thatcher
margot robbie you're going to be so sad
pokeyman why don't robbie just get
featured i don't want to lose
but i don't know how to win i mean is
that an issue you better queens
do i need to know how to win maybe i
don't oh no
[Music]
um
okay it seems to be that we have
forgotten
how to play this game fair assessment
i'm gonna move this because he's gonna
eat it actually be that hard on himself
like she's playing
pretty well it'd be ideal if he didn't
eat it
yeah i mean chess is fun and all yeah
i was i was always kind of curious like
what your take on on that was since you
did compete it's like do you
do you feel like that where it's like
you feel like you put a lot of pressure
on yourself do you just feel since it's
such an individual game
um that it's just like one of those
things where you put too much pressure
on yourself
uh yeah i mean absolutely like there's a
difference between having
your chat members lull when you mess up
in pog when you win
and then a group of you know 30 000
people watching you
on a larger stage and then also like you
know players like
ikaru like i think that's what goes in
most players minds is like oh i'm going
to disappoint my coach
i'm going to disappoint you know whoever
uh is watching
so you just you just feel kind of dumb i
mean for me
you know who you know somehow
accidentally got into the consolation
bracket
it felt as though anything that wasn't
winning would be a failure
especially after you called me the
prohibitive favorite
so that those are the things that are
running through my mind
uh and so when i lost it was it was it
was a sad day it was a lot of pros of
sad i was sad you made me saddy card
and i became the biggest chess room of
all time so who gives a [__] you know
what i mean
money's there baby
[Laughter]
that was an interesting summary that got
there but it
it uh it started with you know grunt
work
disappointing hikaru but then it ended
with with
yeah yeah sir always ends with cash
that's the dream
where does your whole journey video rank
amongst your
your your videos i feel as though oh all
my journey videos i've done a few of
them before but i think they're all
great
it's probably it's like a top 10 video
for me i think it's just you know
because it
it's it's a video that encapsulates like
you know weeks and
even months of work so it's obviously
more effort than just like a day
you know uh
but i don't think her position's too bad
right it's not you know
no it's not combackable
no it's definitely it's it's not
terrible there's there's ways to play
this for
something you you've got to just
basically attack if you sit back and
don't do anything black's material
advantage will become very obvious
and blacks up with three pawns three
pawns yeah but yeah
but it's only pawn she's blunt made
blunders but it's only pawns
correct she hasn't given up the pieces
that matter the most so i think it's
still very possible for some mistakes
to happen yeah if she goes you know
crazy attacking like getting toward h7
this this is the one setup that that
blade uh
i keep getting into sentences where i
have to say blade played
and it's really difficult for me so she
played this setup where you don't get a
belligerent attack on the king and well
yeah i mean she was yelling i don't know
what to do when i don't have my
lightsport bishop
uh we obviously in teaching the
stormwall you have to go all right this
is going to be your backup plan so we
looked at like playing a bit more in the
center
and we'll get there i also feel like
blade
might be just looking at his play the
top two in the group but
he's also with after seeing zex
i don't know it's tough who is the
favorite in this group
yeah the group seems incredibly strong
to be honest probably the strongest
group with just how zex was playing
well i mean there's another group that's
stronger than this objectively i think
which is a group with grip x forsen
um scissors and was it actually hafu no
no it was carson
i was carson right right so i thought
there were three players who were very
very strong
so i think that group might be a little
bit stronger but this group is very
competitive all the players look very
very similar
could be as good as tf blade if not
better
but i think the way i thought of this
and i think the way
she should think of this is group stage
look
you're probably not making it to windows
bracket but that's not even
bad that's not even a bad thing
necessarily right it could be a good
thing
and you can just use these games as like
experience in playing
uh on on the stage with the pressure
with the nerves because there are nerves
oh my god uh and then taking that to the
bracket that's a
that's a great move by the way just
noticing you could do that let's uh
let's listen to blade we haven't done
that
what's he talking about
wait what oh my god i was about to hit
it
what was i thinking with that attack
nearly blundered his queen
closed position right so but you see
he's dragging his
mouse okay well that was odd he just
knew that because he didn't know what to
do my
positioning is like everything's far
away from each other
i mean it's just lack of confidence like
you said it was a great move and i think
he thought that and then when he was
there he didn't know what the line was
then he doubted that it was a good move
and then he was like all right well i'm
going to there's another
queen up here i'm going to attack that
right and also
if you if you notice he drank the very
first thing he did last time
i'm gonna let him talk but she's not
made he what the chicken dragons
[Music]
i've been needing this bishop for so
long i mean it's protecting like these
scores but yeah
tough it's very close position so you
don't feel like you know what you push
up down
and trade straight trades you just take
that for free and then
gets tempo it would probably not be
worth to do that
open queen it would be bad
[Music]
okay
that would be really bad too wait am i
just not seeing any moves or what
[Music]
difficulty of the position yeah
yeah that's a weird thing in chess when
it feels like there's no correct moves
and i need to do some like weird
lame-ish
seeming move that's how it feels some
moves are just okay
is the queen here not bad they're good
[Music]
the pawn structure's so hard to get
through i need subway to break in
at least i can actually just bishop now
really fast
okay i like that he has continuity like
he notices the change in the position
and i really hope she doesn't like queen
takes pawn thinking it's free
right wait what
i don't think she's like dude that's no
that is so unlucky
oh no maybe we can see her reaction but
why
do i always lose my [__]
queen why as
as as anybody would be she is uh
this game pretty frustrated why
why do i do that i do it every game
every single game i just can't get
better at this game
this is insane i don't know what to do
i hate chess me too no i gotta tell you
i hate this game unless i'm playing on
chess.com
i'm just so bad yes
that's the only time i enjoy it
otherwise go away
please go away i just no
stop go away go away
what do i do go here i don't know
i don't know what to do
i'm just gonna like i just i don't scale
i'm not late game let's make me bring up
the big board we'll just talk about it
the uh conversion process in this game i
mean what
what do you do if if that does happen
also it is instructive i mean to look at
it from
from cutie's perspective like bishop
goes back just
scan the board what's it looking at he
looks straight down
between right there and so you would
move the queen
yeah i mean the queen was safe and then
a piece that didn't move forward
threatened it and i think you only look
to see if there's a threat if a piece
moves forward
i think uh it's just harder to see when
it like a retreating piece
isn't usually an attacking piece i think
she just assumed safety
yeah a lot of this also just comes down
to confidence and blade at the end of
the day has played
very confidently even when he's unsure
he just
says i don't know and then keeps
thinking and
goes okay i don't know if this is great
and well now there's
he's taking a good amount of time but he
won't even be close to using all of his
time by the end of the game
right and there's actually a checkmate
here yeah there's a famous checkmate
pattern
do you see it ludwig a famous checkmate
so yeah i i mean probably you didn't see
this i feel like this is a more advanced
concept but there's this notion of
doubled rooks on on a ring so you see
the stacked works for black
yeah black could have actually made
black still has an ability to make a
check with the rook
and then king goes over well we'll show
it we'll show it sure
yeah but black can move the rook over
check over and then use the other work
to swing over and it's checkmate
yes it puts the rooks on those two
highlighted squares
i see so if you you force the king over
to the h file
and then you check again go over the
exactly swing with the other rook
wow yeah that's why one of the more
advanced concepts is these sacked rooks
on the seventh rank because the king is
on the back rank
um is very very powerful if you can get
it
somebody says she's not really a wgm
chess.com gave her that title that is
that's not accurate actually can we not
spread some rumors in chat i mean it's
pretty
clear what's going on here she's wgm
okay i don't that's crazy that rumors
would be spread in this chat
i guess blade is some sort of smurf
you know we do see sometimes you'll play
an untitled player
who is rated significantly lower than
they should be
i mean blade is clearly smurfing clearly
smurfing i mean he did the same thing in
league he's doing the same thing here i
can only hope chess.com mods will ban it
honestly ruining the integrity of the
game he car do you ever smurf come clean
no i don't really nope
is it a thing in chess did not really
did you see that you just liked the
squeak from me sacrifice mate
you did a queen sacrifice mate that was
kind of cool oh my god
but no i to answer a question no no
because it's not that's not really
allowed
i mean you could do it for fun for a
game or two but not it's not something
you can do
um guys let's uh take a quick break i
would imagine and then we are going to
be
joined by judy
and uh and blade for an interview sounds
[Music]
good
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody we've got huge
cinderella and tia blade
lucky enough to be joined by both of
them i uh
i guess first question will be to cutie
before the
match-up you were showing a clip
uh to hype things up yeah what's the
what's the back story between you and
blade maybe you first then we can hear
it from blade's perspective before we
talk chess
yeah um blade he you know desperately
wanted to date me
um and i said no i said no i'm not
interested
and he was really sad for a long time he
actually
didn't handle it kendall couldn't handle
how sad he was
played your perspective it was just a
show man i mean raj
asked like literally asked me i was
doing him a favor right
in my head i did not think about it that
way but yeah
uh yeah it's okay yeah i uh i understand
i you know
i got paid to go on the show it all
works out it's you guys
got to get out all the emotions on the
chest field today how did you feel about
your play tf played first
i thought i was just trolling the entire
time dude i expected myself to have like
eight blunders on the last game
surprisingly
i mean it's at zero but yeah i don't
you summarized your games as trolling
that that's what you said
yeah what so you were trolling you
thought you were trolling then you
looked and you realized you were playing
fine
yeah basically i see i see so your
attempt at trolling was probably better
chess than you even expected
i guess yeah if you put it down all
right fair enough fair enough i guess
that's the new strat what about you
cutie because
i will say you felt like 51
streamer 49 chess player in how you're
playing
you know what i'm gonna say it and this
might be a hot take
i i [__] hate this game i
hate this game i just can't get better
at it and it makes me so angry
um because levi's a bad coach oh
interesting yeah so love he's a bad
coach that's why uh because
yeah have you done any prep at all yeah
i've been playing
a lot i've been i've yeah i lose every
single time i play and i don't
understand why i disagree what
specifically have you played because
when i'm seeing you at night and you're
on the couch you're not actually playing
anything
like i'm on mori if i can just
how many messages you have to receive
you keep getting last time and then i go
on the couch and you're on your phone
you're looking at tick tock or instagram
who knows
last time i checked you're not my coach
okay this is between lebanese
then i'd recognize a student who doesn't
put the [__] work in
you're being mean okay wait a second
wait a second
so i just wanted to ask cutie on air
yes um you've you've done lessons with a
handful of coaches but why do i bear the
brunt of the blame
is it because i'm like the most famous
or
like what it's always me i i'll take it
i'll take it last time
we threw a another person under the bus
so
yes you you have the biggest youtube so
i'm hoping this will go into your
youtube highlights and then in turn
people are like oh i want to follow that
[__] and then they'll follow me
and i'll become famous i'll get all the
money i'll be able to move out of this
closet it'll be amazing
there's a plan i have a plan in place
it's all about the plan in place
i do have to say there's no there's
something about chess
chatters and i i don't i don't this is
hot take there are two women
there are two women in this this
tournament
and there is one that is very very smart
and very very beautiful and very very
talented and then there's me
and it's upsetting to see you i'm going
to say
incels you in cells are so angry that
they let me in here
you're like oh she's so dumb she's so
dumb you know what i can do other things
besides play chess
you guys are all virgins i can get laid
okay you guys can't and i'm
saying it because you're mean you're
mean i'm gonna be mean back
okay all right wait wait wait wait while
you have the floor just one more second
um your next matchup
is either it's either dog or sex row
so fortnite hearthstone um
any thoughts i'm gonna talk as much
trash as i can
but i'm probably gonna lose and i know
that and that's okay
because you know i just you know i i
will win the losers bracket
and that's my goal i will win that by
um i i've been trying to bribe chess.com
i've been sending them money every
single day and it's just like not
working yet but i think i'll hit
i'll make it i'll get enough money we'll
respond soon don't worry um
we we just you know i can't i can't talk
about the specifics but
uh mr blade yes have you scouted the
rest of your group
and what are your thoughts uh you got
any hot takes first of all you you have
the floor you can
bless oh dude no i only played like at
night right now before
i don't know right before going to sleep
i feel like two games or so but i
haven't checked any strategies or
anything
i don't even know what i'm doing i'm
just rolling up pieces but yeah
i will say zextra said the same thing he
said he watched one video and didn't
play for two weeks
and then he beat the highest seed in
your group so i think it'll be tough
yeah
someone's gonna get upset and go to
losers bracket of you three
dog dog yourself or sex row uh we'll see
who it ends up being
uh best of luck on those matches beauty
i think that's
i think i think it's a good goal to win
losers bracket i think of the people we
saw play today
you definitely played better than austin
and connor
who will almost certainly be in losers
bracket
barring death i already know i'm better
than austin and connor that's not a
doubt in my mind
i get paid to send pictures of my feet
they do not so i'm already better than
them based on that alone
we will talk about that after the stream
but i think we should take a look at the
schedule levy
what's going on for the rest of the week
yeah we've got
we've got a lot of uh excitement i mean
first things first uh group x
thorson scissors call me carson david
pakman
xqc is going to be the show tomorrow i
don't know the coverage theme but it's
going to be awesome it's not going to be
as good as today's interviews
but it is going to be pretty awesome and
well you know full schedule
obviously we have rest days because
these are professional chess players
and they do need a day of rest unlike
the previously concluded
uh you know tour that hikaru
participated and they got no breaks
uh these are these are professionals uh
any
any predictions what are we thinking
no predictions off rip but i am excited
to see how carson plays
i hope he uh i hope he just pulls off
one dub in a game not maybe not the set
but the game
person has a good chance he's he's got a
good chance to follow some upsets he's
there are a couple people who played
today who i think are who
did worse yeah i'm excited i think the
latest
bracket will shake i think the losers
bracket will be
won by one of the people in the group
you mentioned one of scissors
or this group we just watched today uh
because i think i think one of them are
it's gonna feel very out of place
in a group with connor austin carson uh
you know who likely will be in that pool
maybe with you know pac-man maybe xqc
will have a good chance at it we'll see
i'm excited for the losers bracket
though you guys know me i'm a loser's
bracket fanatic
these groups are crazy like it it's it's
so difficult to predict and
we we all know that at the end of the
day
it sort of feels not like an uphill
battle but it but it feels like there is
one player in particular
who is trying to assemble all of the
infinity stones of coaching right
and uh well it's just
cool to see that there's a there's a
playing field of guys that you say
things like
you know i don't play until i sleep or i
don't play in two weeks
and they still show up in place i feel
like there is a uh
maybe it's true but a desire to let it
be known how little they're playing
chess
uh and unless they win the whole thing
who gives a [__]
but hey if they win the whole thing and
they haven't played a day that's cool
uh but if they if they end up getting
you know seventh then
all right great impressive
uh i'm excited to see the box boxes
those are the people i like the most
hours and are proud of it and then win
the whole thing or do the best they can
do the best they can uh i wanna i wanna
hear a prediction hikaru
group x versus forsen who you got
um i'm gonna predict fourson based on
the fact that i think gripex was
a little bit too nervous in his first
match against scissors and i think
playing playing
another guy from scandinavia he's going
to be feeling the pressure there are
obviously a lot of force and supporters
all the buys will be out
so i think forsen will pull through and
win that match scissors carson obviously
with the way scissors played he's a bit
of a bit of a favorite but carson
played pretty well in the opening
against um yeah i think
scissors can manage his time and not get
too low on the clock he'll probably win
um if he doesn't i think it's going to
be a competitive match so i think
scissors is the favorite but he has to
stay ahead on the clock not get too low
because otherwise i think carson will
have a legitimate chance
and last but not least mr xqc hopefully
he doesn't stay up for another
500 hours and he's playing david pakman
so solidity
versus i'm concerned for xqc based on
what i saw from david pakman with a lot
of the tricky type of openings against
um
against hafu i think he's going to come
with more more of those sorts of tricks
and i i i think he's probably going to
win that match but i'm going to pick
pac-man
wow well that just about concludes it
here for us
this was a a lot of excitement we saw a
lot of first-time things like open mic
trash talking
uh gentlemen it was a pleasure being
with you
i don't know we're probably to send the
right over to somebody and we will
continue tomorrow
with uh coverage of park champs too same
time as always
you better be here that was good guys
thanks again
[Music]
so
you